the 2020 u.s junior championship
features 10 of the strongest chess
players in america
under the age of 20. over the course of
nine rounds
these competitors will battle for six
hundred dollars in prize money
and bragging rights as the best young
player in the united states
this year's competitive field will
showcase seven players who are among the
top 100 juniors on the planet
including world number five sam savion
and world number two
jeffrey zhang who won the world junior
championship
in 2016. the future of u.s chess is on
full display
in what should be an intense battle all
the way to the finish line
[Music]
welcome to championship october
we have four events left for you and
today
we bring you the start of the 2020
u.s junior championship one of
my favorite events i am jennifer jahady
and i'm
here today with grand masters yasser
sarawan and maurice ashley
to call this event full of talent hello
yes
hello jennifer as always delighted to be
with you
and a big welcome back to maurice nice
to be alongside you my friend calling
the action indeed this is the second
national championship
in this october-filled national
championship month
and i gotta tell you i love the junior
championships i
played in quite a number myself they
were intense
intense affairs and these young men have
a lot
to play for and a lot to prove maurice
welcome back maurice as
oops i think he might be um he might be
you know we've missed him for so long
yeah i know
now we have to wait another minute just
a second
let me release the mute button that i
might have
inadvertently pressed i'm sorry maurice
are you still with us
i guess not you know what why don't we
take a look at the players
exactly we'll get back to that let's
take a look at this outstanding field
that we have in store in the next
week well we've got next three days
rather well we've got
jefferies young one of the top players
in the us he's 19 years old
sam sevion our second seed also an
incredible
star and we love to see sam play but
some of these other players
i haven't gotten a chance to call their
games as much as i would have liked
i see them at the national high school
championships the us open
but now here they are playing the u.s
junior championship for that coveted
u.s championship spot exactly and as i
look at our player roster i'm
just drawn by the fact that five
of the ten players are grandmasters and
i just find that
absolutely incredible jen it just goes
to show
what a great talent uh we have and what
about our format for
this event jen well it looks just
like the u.s junior girls clothes which
we just called and karissa yip won that
we're gonna have ten
play around robin that means three games
a day so there's ten players everybody
plays
nine players time control game 25 with a
five second increment love this time
control
allows for us to explore some of the
nice keys and the early moves
while it gets really fun and wild
towards the end
um and they're playing for prize money
and there will be a champion as there
will be a tie break for first place if
you need it
and just the schedule one more time
three games a day you mentioned but
also tiebreak on our third day if we
need it and i feel like this
field is very feisty so yeah you may
need it
the meteorology report is saying high
chances of playoff on october 15th
um this is this is going to be great and
we do i believe have grandmaster moore
is ashley back
welcome back to the show as he
is going to run down some of our
favorites and one of our newcomers
you know i'm so excited to jump in and
say hello to you guys
and then find out you guys can't hear me
it's one of those
quirks of technology i don't know what
happened in fact
but i think we have it all straightened
out now so yes
thanks for being back on the show and
yes i'm excited as well to see the
future
of american chess on full display
it's incredible when you think about all
the youngsters like yourself back in the
day yes
who played in these marvelous events the
future stars
who will emerge as truly indeed the ones
who
will compete for u.s championship titles
for decades to come
and of course we see this amazing lineup
and
two players stand out jeffrey zhang
and sam sevillan who will not only be
playing in this event but
also in the us championship
as well these two incredible
young players i've already played in u.s
championships but this will be their
last ever us junior as they will age out
vote this year will turn 20 years old
and let's talk about these players a
little bit more jeffrey zhang of course
we know he is a star
he is a high level player already
one of the top players in the world this
19 year old from texas
won the world junior championship back
when he was only a
16 year old and now saying well
i belong at the elite of the elite he is
the fifth best player in the country
which makes him the fifth board the
alternate on the olympic team
he's played he seems like a veteran
actually as
such a youngster he's played in so many
u.s championships already remember he
broke even
in one of them he is one to watch
certainly
here at this event as he could easily
run up the score against the field but
then we have sam savion
he doesn't want to be in jeffrey's
shadow also 19 from massachusetts
he has won the 2017 american continental
championship the youngest ever winner in
fact
of that event and sam has
been here for so long he's the youngest
grand master in u.s history
at the moment youngest ever beating out
all the likes of the nakamura's even
jeffrey jones
he is certainly a star player and
remember he
played in this in the u.s championship
when he was only 12.
youngster coming in but now a veteran
at 19. he doesn't want to play second
fiddle to
anyone at all and speaking of youngsters
christopher you only 13 years old
he held the record at the time in 2016
of becoming the youngest ever master in
u.s chess
at age nine that record has since been
broken but the spirit of this young man
will not be a
simply a rising star 13 he'll
have his hands full and look at all
those
books sir that that library
rivals yours what an amazingly well
ready youngster at such a tender age
extraordinary he is one to watch in this
event as well
remarkable for sure uh maurice fantastic
and jen let's take a look at the first
round
pairing start us off what do you think
all right let's take a look i did want
to see another look at that bookshelf
though i didn't see
chess stools
we yeah to work on the quality we've had
some great pairings as always
christopher yu is going to play against
san seveon
a huge battle as one of the youngsters
plays
one of the veterans of the event if you
can call anyone in a junior event a
veteran sam
is the closest one to it as well as his
um
his other contender um for favorite in
the event jeffrey jung the highest rated
player
playing against john burke they both
start with the black pieces
you know we've been seeing jeffrey a lot
lately as the underdog
right playing against magnus carlsen and
clutch chess playing in the st louis
rappin and blitz and now we get to see
him
as the one who's supposed to run the
table
yeah he he's definitely a rating
favorite can he do it and what are they
playing
well they're playing for over twenty
thousand dollars including 6k for first
place
and hey first place is even sweeter
because it also comes
with a six thousand dollar college
scholarship as donated by dwayne barber
and u.s chess
so first place is like 12k um
some sweet change for these juniors
i was going to say in my day the prize
money was the
opportunity to represent the u.s in the
world
junior championship that was what we
were playing for
but it's nice to see these these players
have a little money in their pocket
maurice
absolutely and i'd be curious jeffrey i
don't think
probably has any intention of going to
college anytime soon
he is trying to be the best player
on the planet i mean that's his
aspiration
and rightly so young 19 year old 2700
he wants to make a leap and i'm sure
he's working as intensely as possible
to make the leap from the low 2700s
which of course is still
fantastic to the high 2700s which will
put him in the top
five even in the world if he's if he's
27
90 95 he's number four on the planet i
mean that's
that's what we're talking about as
dingleren's rating dropped i believe to
27.90
off from his 2800 peak
that would put him in that realm so he
he needs to figure out guys
how am i going to get to that next tier
can i make that breakthrough
will he or won't he it's very hard to
say we've got all these great youngsters
these days alareza farouza for example
playing magnificently well
but he has his eyes on being the best on
the planet
or at least among the best that's right
now you guys might notice the one player
that is missing in this event a wander
leong
um he unfortunately had a scheduling
conflict something that he agreed to do
before
the dates come out for this event but he
will be back with us at the us chess
championships and hey i'm gonna miss a
smile
but we'll see him in a couple weeks yes
absolutely and as you were talking
marisa is thinking about the grand chess
tour and that's got to be uh jeffrey's
goal
if he can make it to the grand chess
tour then he's really really justified
in missing the college university and
you mentioned he's the number two player
in the world
the number one judge number two junior
in the world
the the number one junior is alireza
ferrugia
who's tearing it up in norway leading
a very elite field including
magnus and fabi these juniors are tough
man these juniors are rough it's not
like the old days
and by the way jeffrey is the number
uh sorry sam is the number five junior
on the planet
as well so we're talking about some
elite
players in this event and it's not just
them because we have a number of juniors
in this event who are among the top 100
juniors
in the world so very powerful
junior championship for this country but
here's the thing guys
jeffrey john might be the number two
rated player in the world junior but
he's the number one rapid
and this is rapid checks he's higher
rated than
in rapid rating which is something i
think we noticed um
in the uh st louis rockman blitz that he
played and that that makes sense i mean
jeffrey's you know um plays a lot of
blitz he's you know got one of the
highest scorers in history and puzzle
rush
like he's got that kind of fast twitch
um
brain as most of the juniors do but
particularly jeffrey
so yeah uh he's up there he's got that
and by the way
jeffrey was leading magnus carlson in
clutch chess if he
exactly i remember that was rapid as
well
he showed that he can swing with the
best of them
he's got to be the pick i mean he's got
to be the pick for this event
and the moves have started yeah the
games have been underway for
a few minutes uh but unfortunately
in the game between john burke and
jeffrey zhang what we thought would be
our marquee
matchup between these two grand masters
we haven't seen any moves so the game
i'd like to go to
is between nicholas and brandon
the reason i want to go to this
particular game
is because this is an opening or rather
a defense
that i cherished a lot um
a lot of my opponents i i used to play
the queen's gambit accepted big time
and my opponents to avoid the queen's
gambit accepted
oftentimes played against me knight f3
c5
d4 this very very specific
move order and my games oftentimes
continued
exactly as did the game between brandon
and nicholas
now my good opponents actually castled
here
and i think that's a very important move
uh
nicholas uh in view of the move e5 e4
played the automatic d2 d3 a very
natural move a move might we
all might play unthinkingly and there's
a problem
which i actually uh worked out
very well myself bishop b4 check this is
an incredibly important check that
really messes up white's position a lot
it's really surprising
that after just five moves white could
seize a disadvantage
after the move bishop before check the
problem is if you
put your knight in the way of the bishop
it makes it that much harder to play the
move e2 e3 and this is very important
for example a5 a3 bishop back
castles knight here we're in a benoni
where e2 e3 is automatic you play e2e3
but you can't because your stupid knight
is in the way
and the pawn on d3 hangs you'll end up
having to play some goofy move like
knight g5
if you play as in the game bishop d2 and
this is
very important by brandon he realizes
uh the necessity for playing a7 a5
now once again if you play at a kind of
a benoni
like move like a3 the bishop can drop
back anywhere c5 d6 e7
i'm just picking a square and once again
it's
very awkward to get in e2 e3 and the
knight on b1 is saying
excuse me what is my role so it's a very
intriguing
opening that after only five moves
bishop b4 check bishop d2
i actually prefer black's position
in five moves and white hasn't done
anything optically
wrong interesting
that if you continue the game though a
couple moves in he did remove his bishop
from that d2 square with the move bishop
to g5
and can now start thinking about the
same idea
this is going to be an interesting
battle
but look at another one that has taken
on
incredibly sharp angles
is the game between christopher you and
the number two seed
sam sevion the youngest player in the
event and sam
and if you look at the way this opening
transpired just
right out the gate this was sharp
you know people say d4 d5 can be boring
uh yeah what's the big deal but look at
this
queen b3 in this uh rogozin look like to
start with bishop g5
on the board c5 in response to queen b3
that's a sharp line there
and now bishop to g5 quickly met by
knight c6 and they've been banging out
moves by the way
banging out the moves takes on c5 takes
on c4 trades
and now this move queen a5 saying i
don't care if you crack my pawn
structure
on f6 and go after my pawn
on f6 i don't care i'm going to go for
your c5 pawn
and now queen h4 attacking the f6 pawn
and look at this
next move king e7 nestling in on
87 square okay white ins i mean
just about instantly played the move g3
ignoring everything saying i'm just
going to develop pieces normally like
nothing happened
well you know um i just got a shout out
from varusa nakobian
and he said that there's been um 44
games played in this position and that
must be
why um christopher is moving so fast
absolutely
absolutely the theory in this line but
it just goes to show these
players are so prepared but you've got a
young christopher you
13 years old and we see him on camera
there uh
i haven't seen him play but i'm watching
him and it's only 13 moves and
and how many minutes few maybe five
minutes into the game
and he's bouncing and going back and
forth
wow this you know some players have that
california cool
we see magnus do we the stoic look of a
jeffrey zhang
we we have a bit of an emotional uh
i don't know what you might call it
mover on our screen people get excited
i'm a bit like a bouncer that might be a
better word
bouncy you know he's excited and the
good thing about playing online is
you're not distracting your opponent
so if you want to like bounce a little
bit in your chair move your head around
it's not like sam's getting distracted
right
right there are some benefits i guess to
being
playing from the privacy of your home
now speaking of homes seven's background
is gorgeous it looks like some set
designer
worked on it i just wish i knew who that
beautiful portrait was of
behind him that's a nice artwork
it really is he's getting some nice nice
artwork there
have to ask him about it now in the
meanwhile sam is actually the one
burning clock and it's christopher as
you mentioned maurice who's just been
you know triggered he's he's pushing out
his moves and sam is actually
wondering okay he's setting his own
internal clock like
what am i supposed to do i've got three
pieces
that i need to develop and should i be
going on a long diagonal should i be
playing bishop d7 and developing my
rooks
should i be taking advantage or trying
to take advantage of the fact that this
queen is maybe
a little bit away from the action it's
not on d2 for example and this rook is
hanging
and after spending some minutes
he decided that well yeah why not
uh press matters on the queen side and
he hit the rook with queen a3
well verusion should let us know what's
happening here as christopher
has either forgotten his preparation
or has never seen this move queen a3
because maybe it's a novelty
and is wondering what's the deal i mean
the most obvious move on the board is
rook to c2 just move the rook
guard everything guard your a-pawn keep
the ground from being able to make any
incursions
that seems like the most obvious move c3
is hanging if you move the rook away
and your queen could go to f4 and try to
come back home but that seems like
okay it does seem like an alternate e5
would be a kick followed by a bishop
entering the frayed f5 so i think rook
c2 looks
in my estimation as the best move and it
looks like he's
eventually did settle on the move
but as you said he blitzed out literally
blitzed out his first few moves
now this rook on c2 if it remains stable
bishop goes to g2 castles
it's going to be somebody's king in the
middle of the board i mean and it's not
going to be whites
right yeah it's if you have queen a3 by
the way var says is very rare
only played twice so the fact that
christopher
is still banging out moves
really feel something and now wow well
getting seasick a little bit there is
he's
really moving now right uh
i like rooksy too indeed maurice it's
the most natural move on the board
you attack my rook you attack my pawn i
move my rook and i protect my pawn
no question about it but i was actually
thinking that the queen is actually
misplaced on a3
and i'm like go ahead put your queen on
a3 for all it's worth
yeah i really like queen h6
the idea behind queen h6 is yes you're
absolutely right i'm telegraphing bishop
g2
castles but once i get my queen over
here to h6
i just introduce just a little bit more
of a tug
uh against black's king side with the
move queen g7
also with my queen posted up on h6 it
means that that king
if it ever had any ideas of maybe
scurrying back to the king side
i don't know exactly how but if it had
such plans
they're uh put and so that would have
been that would have been a sacrificial
line yes you'd have to prove
queen a2 would be no a nothing
concept not saying you do it necessarily
immediately but
sure you know because e2 will hang later
as well so after bishop d7 there is
a bit of bridge burning going on in this
particular line
so clearly a sharp line that he decided
well
not today maybe later but not today to
risk
giving away material for some
compensation
now this move to me e5 is also a worry i
have
against the move quick
is a disturbing move i mean it will
create some issues now is it really
great if i
when i play the move e4 against you at
some point e4
attacking the bishop maybe that's not a
real threat so we can
play for bishop g2 and keep the ideas
going
this position is sharp and i think the
durability of that king
on the e7 square is going to be a factor
black is gonna have to aim for something
like h5 rogue g8 rook g4
kind of action that's going to be sharp
folks we're out the gate with some heat
right away here in these u.s junior
championships
absolutely i also like i i don't like
being disturbed by the move bishop f5 i
i like my pawn on the e2 square because
i want to utilize the e4 square
maybe for a night maneuver maybe because
i want my bishop diagonal to be open
so i would probably temporize with a
move like bishop h3
stop being bishop f5 for the time being
you mentioned
also maurice that a rook might show up
on g4
well i'll nip that idea in the bud
before it's even born
kid played it yes kid channeled you and
he played it
it's on the board exactly and if you
trade bishops
that helps me bring a knight to the
unbelievably
powerful f5 square so i like the move
bishop h3
and sam is under pressure out of the
get-go our number two seed
uh um under uh
under duress a little bit let's take a
look at john
and uh jeffrey as we do have some moves
in that game it looks like an
alakan now you both are kind of e4
players what's your
impressions of the alekhine i was always
annoyed by it
always annoyed i never felt like i could
get what i
really wanted against alaka i never had
a big line against it
uh managed to draw your malinsky with it
in in the u.s championship the one i
played in
but i you know i have a good friend
willie johnson
who loves him some
alekhine defense look like he'll just
tell you everything about it he learned
it from
lev albert who you used to play
absolutely
very much so who was a specialist in the
alakan and he could just quote any line
you don't even
vary one iota because he'll say that's
not book come on
what are you doing here you better be
you better be making up some great
novelty because that's not in
the book anywhere and i always find it
very
difficult especially since most people
never played it and i think that it's
it's a good line if you want to win play
for a win with black
we've seen shabala have used it on
occasion as well
um magnus oh yes in the st louis rappin
and blitz indeed and i think that
um to answer he has this question if
i wasn't if i was ready for the alakan i
was excited to play against it like if i
knew my opponent was going to play it so
i could prepare
right we just use alakin as a surprise
weapon right so that's right
that's always hard because yeah it seems
and i think one of the things also
psychological
that you feel like white should have a
bigger edge than usual when they play
the alkyne
right so it's easy to get frustrated
when your position's just
meh okay exactly and
the only player i really
in the elite was lev alberta who you
mentioned
there uh maurice who played it uh
consistently
and hit was his number one defense a a
couple of players nigel short
uh magnus carlson vacillo levon chuck
they that's a good list yeah that's a
good list of names right
you said shabbat also got to mention
there
so i mean a lot of really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you can or can't hear us at the moment
it's because there is a little bit of
technical stuff going on but
nevertheless we will continue
and we we are back
indeed we are back there was some
technical difficulties
indeed uh the ghost is in the machine
everyone never know when it's going to
happen as we are
we have been working on it but we've
been enjoying the game and not this move
rook
ad8 by s
by sam exciting position but yes you
said you wanted to take us to another
position
i did it was absolutely crazy uh game
was going on between bryce and josh
and i just even i looked like it came
from
an advanced car con it did indeed
and the short defense
and looking at the game between bryce
and josh in this move g7 g5
okay i was the women's uh olympic team
uh captain in
baku in azerbaijan and
uh one of our ladies
katja played against the g7 g5
variation and what a beautiful game so i
actually have good memories of this line
for white and even though i'm a car
con player well also if you move forward
a little bit
you'll see that um as we see the live
board on the screen white is also off a
pawn
he played the move h4 exactly yeah
to undermine the g5 pawn which he ended
up capturing
and this is where we're up to date on
and this looks like it just not just an
extra pawn but
it's a it's a pawn with uh relish
because after move like knight g4 it's
like
another unusual construction maurice two
bishops fending off
these two nights but these two nights
look really good and again it's a
it's a pawn in the pocket for white
that's what i was going to say
your knights look really good when
you're out material as well
exactly and and the reality is they
cannot uh
be kicked out i mean you know h3 you
never
see you never see knights on g4 and g5
just think about that knights on g4 and
g5 i don't have to do a research
bit of research to see how many times
this has happened in chess history and
especially when there are
no pawns in the g-file or h-file for
black
as well i can assure you this doesn't
happen regularly in chess
this is a wild strange distribution
a disturbance in the force
position it is very difficult um to
imagine this being good for black
because it's not just the knights i mean
the
thing normally yaz is the one pounding
the table for the extra pawn but this is
like
more than a pawn guys this is also like
a really key pawn
normally like i sacrificed something to
rip off open like one of your
your pawns defending your king right
like get get rid of h7 or get rid of g7
now they're just both gone
and you have no you have no material
compensation for it you're actually down
upon here
um this looks fantastic for white after
knight g4
if you could only put a queen on g3 you
know i'm always fantasizing about where
my pieces belong put a queen on g3 you'd
have a massive
lineup on the g file well slow burn
one for for history that simply
i don't know that's ever occurred in
chess history in fact the
insane setup the bishop on g6 the bishop
on g7
two knights on the g line like this the
knight on g5 is easy to envision
but on g4 as well wild
very interesting just from curiosity
standpoint
but it does look as though white is just
dominating here i mean
how can it be any any other way where's
the counter play for black
i like your idea though of playing like
queen d2 queen f4
queen h2 um slow but somehow we need to
get that monarch over
to the king side and it doesn't what
other route do we have right
like that seems like a decent one maybe
e3 to h3
um queen d2 queen e3 queen h3 well the
trick is
what does black do if you're looking at
this from vice president you say what is
black's
next move or next two moves
uh queen b6 to try to attack this pawn i
i could
maybe play bishop to b2 uh so that i can
keep my
my thread of bringing the queen up and
over
what do you call that jen you call the
rook up and over
a rover what do you call the queen up
and over
a quover doesn't sound quite as
elegant but that could be a possibility
as well and then
black house quiver queen quiver that
sounds good doesn't it queen quake
we got to work on that one let's let's
try to get the right one let's try to
get the right
phrase but uh the right terminology
because it will stick
you know when you make up a nice term
like rover it ends up
sticking so uh this one looks like it's
all white but what i'm really interested
in is
back to the game with the youngster
between you
christopher you and sam sevilla and
there were a lot of maneuvers made
and it's still that night well dying to
go to f5
and boy lucky for sam
at the moment there's no way to just
break into his position with a pawn
break
of some kind but you just feel like
clouds
dark clouds are hanging over his
position but potentially
yeah absolutely a lot of decisive games
i think we're gonna get in this first
round
um dude yeah what do you what do you see
here
yes for um sam
what's your prognosis
oh i think maybe after
e4 um
maybe we need to try to play because my
king is so
terrible in the center of the board um
and knight f5
check looks like it's coming with a bang
so i certainly want to try to chase your
queen with something like queen g4
it looks like we've lost the asser for
them yeah that's why yeah that's why i
didn't let him answer my question
man we have some we have some weird
stuff going on is he
dr cyrimar we need him uh because
this is this is your kind of sweet
positional grind yasser where you just
flick the right moves in
and get him on his back foot and i'm
really liking white's game right now
heck yeah as he's setting up in sound i
was mentioning the move queen g4
and one thing i will not do is let you
trade queens in this position with your
king on e7 right
because the king in the center is
actually could be good in the end game
but in the middle game it's treacherous
so you play queen g4 luckily for white
or not just luckily by design
i do have one square to avoid the queen
trade and i'll
i'll take it in an instant i'll play
queen e3
um and i i don't know maurice i mean
maybe
sam will have to play something like
rook g8 but
hey one of the top seeds looks to be in
serious trouble
absolutely and the king has nowhere to
go the king wishes and
the best case that it was sitting on the
b7 square because if you've got to sit
on f8 and disconnect your rooks
you could really end up being in a lot
of trouble in that position and
so knight f5 looks great also what i
like is the potential
to play the move f4 if i'm white
and put both my rooks on the f file
that's a danger that's brewing in the
position as well
uh we i'm seeing a lot of arrows in that
analysis board that must be yasser
screen that's
frozen for the moment he's got all the
ideas he's like
hit him hit him all kinds of different
ways in this position
with knight f5 a check just being
a boss looking move but christopher
seems to be holding that move back
for the moment at least and the time
is a lot closer than it was before as we
could expect
as he's trying to figure out exactly
what he needs to do in the position
and he has started with queen e3
interesting so he did choose
that move to kick it off with queen d7
immediately from sam
who doesn't want to get in time pressure
to exacerbate his tough position on the
board
he also didn't want to see rook d2
happen but
what do you do about the move
knight f5 and by the way while that's
happening we need to get back to bryce
and
josh's game because something explosive
happened on the board
absolutely huge as
black sacrificed a piece
after knight c6 uh he played knight
h3 and knight d4 happened
with a bang that was not
i'm not sure that's what he had planned
or he had seen this line coming
because he's just dropped bishop a3 on
the board as well
so he in fact it's now black who's up
material right so black
temporarily sacrificed on d4 to get
bishop takes e5 taking a second pawn and
we'll know that yasser's sound is
working again when he
starts getting excited about that but
more importantly you're also gaining the
rook on a1 which is
undefended so it's not just an exchange
you're taking that rough
uh so materially black is
up in exchange and upon but guess what
the king is still weak maurice i mean
this is still not out of the woods yet
for black at all like bishop a3 and
knight f4 i
i still think white has some very big
attacking chances but
that move knight h3 was weird
definitely a mistake going in the wrong
direction can't understand why he didn't
play knight g4
and taking on f8 is wide just getting
the material back he said look i got to
get something back
i'm down upon i did blunder my material
advantage
this is not something he wanted to see
happen on the board black now has
the two bishops that beautiful dark
square bishop we were
basically putting josh in the coffin
a few moves ago now white's the one
that's
begging for the dirt not to be put on
him
as he's found himself down material for
zero reason he just missed
this tactic of knight takes on d4
yeah i think that uh he must miss knight
before right because he that's what
happens sometimes when all the trumps in
the position are yours right you have
all the good things in your position so
you forget about your opponent's counter
play
and i think that's what um joshua prayed
to in this game but
you know i mean bryce uh why would he
play knight why would he play knight h1
on knight g4 looks
so good knight f4 now though
black's if queen takes f8 knight f4
black
white still has compensation right he's
down a pawn but
your king is still exposed and how are
you going to deal with that attack on
your
bishop on g6 i got 95 hitting your queen
guarding the bishop uh yeah i have to
play i mean
g3 yeah you're you know you still have
work to do to prove that you have
anything and
at the moment it's still a pawn
and of course this is not going to be
easy because of the exposure
of black's king there's going to be
potential chances but once everyone gets
to the c
file starts to come into the game shut
down your most aggressive
possibilities especially now that uh 95
queen g3 gains a tempo rook c8 rook is
coming to c3
this is not going to be
any kind of better roses white is going
to have to try
his best to breathe in
admit the blunder and say you know what
i screwed up
that's what happened how do i get my
head back in this game
in this position because he's in a world
of trouble now
speaking of potential trouble we see in
the game again and keep coming back to
this like a broken record with
christopher you
and sam cevion christopher he's not
wasting
any time i mentioned that idea of f4 and
he's
going for it breaking open the position
with f4 going after sam saying
i'm not intimidated i know you're the
number five junior on the planet yeah
yeah
you're 26 26.50 right sure whatever i'm
only 13.
okay i'm a little kid i know how about
this move right here
bam f4 let's go for it i want to double
rooks
on the f file and i want to come get you
this
is a precocious youngster indeed
looking for his chances and he has
doubled
rooks on the f-file i'm not liking it
i'm smelling an upset in the making guys
absolutely i mean the question is the
timing because you you want to make sure
that when you take on e5
um you you have the right timing because
uh
that knight only five could be powerful
but the problem is
there's also the pressure on the f7 font
so pawnee 5 25 knight g6 is an immediate
threat that just wins the game
so queen d3 played obviously
we do not want to trade queens as white
right unless we're winning a boatload of
material
so i i predict queen well queen c1 looks
like the right move because it also
looks at that a3 diagonal
which could gain a tempo queenie one
also
i mean just keeping those queens on the
board and renewing the threats of taking
on e5
how do you stop it well the thing about
this last move is he kept his e-pawn
alive so he's
he's playing zero risk chess
this is i know yasser is just crying
that his audio is not working right
now because this is the the kind of
attack where he actually says i'm
sacking nothing
i have all the edges and this is how i
beat people up
all day long what do you do as black
your rooks are split your king's exposed
on the f8 square
black is is got a queen on d3 but
what else what are you gonna do with it
nothing your knight can only come in the
game
if white says it's coming in the game by
capturing on e5
the potential of a pawn hitting
the pawn on f6 dropping is just
exponential right now
i don't even know how you're going to
save this pawn f7 is hanging knight g's
i mean
i'm seeing too many threats and white
hasn't sacrificed anything yet
why did i sacrifice zero for this
position it's really looking horrific i
mean let's just
right now pawn takes e5 seems to be a
really devastating threat
so black has to do something to prevent
that from just
winning the game so we have to defend f7
right or um or we have to
have enough tactics so that if 25 95
we're not that worried about rick takes
ourselves so ricky gets played
why should this position though i mean
why should white be afraid
i understand it's not going to be that
easy but
i'm i'm of the gary kasparov school
that says you got to give something to
get something
now the karpovian school the petrosian
school
they give you nothing you get nothing
while i'm squeezing you to death but the
other school
the the more aggressive type the tall
school the kasparov squeezes
you get a knight on e5 i admit that's
that's dynamic
but i am going to show that i have more
firepower than you do so f takes e5 is
something i think that white
will want to do even though a knight
lands on the e5 square because black is
just simply going to be
bereft of opportunities to really attack
white
while it's going to be the reverse for
for the other way now
aren't we winning a pawn right now we're
taking on e5 that's got to be calculated
immediately takes on e5
and then and takes on e5 and then takes
on f6
i don't really want to trade off pieces
but
that does look like i think the only
worry
for me is white is i don't even i don't
even want to trade into a pawn
up end game i'm sorry [ __ ]
shivers going down inside because i want
to check mate black so like suppose
95 rook f6 rook f6 knight g4
i'm with you i'm with you i yeah even if
we win material is
it's no fun but it's but it's the safety
line
that's the safety line now i did like
knight f5
in that position actually knight f5
looks strong as well
ah knight f5 instead of snatching the
pawn so my concern was after rook f6
rook f6 um that after knight g4 you'd
get a little queen e3 business going on
and trade off the queens
um that's not attractive at all
yeah yeah but i'm not meeting you so i
had my hopes
you're not meeting but that's not
attractive like at all why who wants to
go into a queen ending
where you're in deep trouble you're
you're you're just bailing into
a technical affair where white's the one
who's better by the way who says you
even get this in-game knight g4 rook f3
lands on the board you don't get a check
right
oh and just just to clarify if knight g6
what happens um if knight g6 the problem
is we just
move our king and then when you take our
rook on h8 we take your rook on f6
yeah no that's not yes that's not just
yet
so now he's played king to
e7 he's asking for it
king e7 i just want to play rook f5
and you can't play f6 because i'll take
it and play knight g6
so i want to play rook f5 and ask you
what you do with your knight by the way
black is one tempo away
from getting his rook in the game so
he's just a move away
so we don't want him to get any chance
we don't want to breathe just yet
there's also an idea no rook f2 is not
what i want to do because you're going
to play rook to d8
and maybe he might even play rook c8 to
try to get his counter play against
this pawn on c3 so we need to keep
harassing black
rook f5 would be my suggestion in this
position
white has white by the way the youngster
13 years old with a two result
game if he's careful if he goes into a
boring position he doesn't lose
if he slips up he might give sevilla a
chance but this is
white's game to control how the rest of
this goes
and whether or not he gets the draw in
his pocket uh or he wins the game
rook at five is um a funny move in a way
because we've been dying to get our
knight on f5 all game and now we're like
we're taking we're taking that square
for our work instead but you're right
it's that concrete
reality that you can't play f6 to
protect the knight
and if you can't do that it's very
troublesome because
if you move the knight away work d5 and
suddenly i'm trading places
i'm getting the best of both worlds i
put my work on d5 and my knight on f5
and that's just gonna be the end of the
world
you know there's a complex line there by
the way rook five
we could we after f6 we could win the
rook in the corner but the knight might
get
trapped in the corner and we'd find
ourselves in a queen
ending that might not be as good as
uh as we want it to be in rook five on
the board
but that would be a deep defensive line
as i see yasser's face is back in the
picture i'm hoping
his audio is back yeah sir we've been
dying to get
oh there you go here's dr sierwan and
this position
sir i mean you've been silent long
enough
this one feels like your touches are
needed
something something silky smooth
to really put black out of his misery
yeah it it it feels like there
should be an absolute ko
but i don't see it and you mentioned
yourself maurice that
there is this uh very clever
way of losing a piece but somehow
miracle of miracles getting yourself
into a queen ending
um well you it's not a knockout
what about queen f2 here with the idea
that we're going to take a
a now we can now we can extricate our
knight right
with knight f7 is that true they're
going to be some checkies
in the building queen b and then and
then
queen back and your king is not going
anywhere oh yeah and i can't i can never
play queen f3
well you might be able to play you might
be able to you'll have the outside
passer in that yeah
that's yeah i have to calculate that
pawn
right you would have to calculate it
and sam played the alternative to f7 f6
sam played king e6 he said okay let me
defend
my night with my king that's leading
with your chin to be sure
let me defend the night with my king
okay well that seems like a very bold
move i'm
dying to find an attacking possibility
here i know i know you want to play
light
yeah well it doesn't allow native three
chak exactly
um i'm wondering about getting my queen
in like queen
i want to go like queen c1 and pop a
queen into g5 or something like that but
hey there's
there's playing on both goals that's the
problem right
king e6 move is like is really
extraordinary
what is that what do you call it
gangster chess i mean yes
absolutely wow
well what about queen c1 though because
is queen e4 too greedy i mean queen
queen e4 would be the one thing that i'd
be afraid of right
exactly exactly we don't have that and
then i am coming in to age six with
check right like you can't play rook the
eight anymore
um look look look at that chris chris
is bouncing now right
here between h6 here so after queen e4 i
mean sorry queen g5
queen g5 so i was saying if you move
your rook i always have queen h6 winning
the game
but what about queen g5 is the problem
you just check me to death or something
i don't see a lot of good
queen b1
b1 might be good to stay in the light
squares but you prefer you on yes
i don't know uh rook one doesn't stop
all checks i don't understand why
okay let's see checks don't lead
anywhere right that's
the that's the weirdness right like i
don't know where to put my rook let's
let me just pick a a crazy square for a
moment
but queen f6 jack now right i guess
you're just going to d5 okay talk about
gangster winning i know running up the
board
uh maybe night after you play like three
it could be a calm
winning move there you played with that
one by the way you just dropped back
with us rook
um just saying that well
i want to play queen f2 and queen f5
queen f6
ideas i love this move you like it
i love this move very practical move on
his part
guess what you can give away the pawn as
white in this position give away one if
your positional advantage transforms and
then endures
you could give away a pawn you just have
to be very careful that king
does not finally end up on b7 that is
the
biggest danger here is that somehow the
king gets over there but he's looking to
play queen of two
and queen f6 and if you can end up on b7
if i damage everything else i win the h
pawn and you know consolidate into a
winning endgame when my h-pawn is
running down the board
but this kind of plays very mature on
the part very practical as well
and sam down to just 343 on the clock
in that position so wow it's not looking
good
not looking good for him also not
looking good for jeffrey jean
as white pieces if this is the alekhine
yeah i'm gonna follow this guy because
john
burke is hunting jeffrey look at these
gorgeous pieces that white has in this
position
sure does i mean the knight on e5 is a
dream
bishop on d4 the doubled uh
queen on e3 rookie one and by the way
rook on c7
really bothersome you start to think hey
does
knight f7 um produce the goods the
problem as i see it is this knight on d6
is absolutely stuck
you don't want to see a d5 d6
opening up this bishop so a lot of
dangers in the position for jeffrey
and white on the move i mean it just
sorry i i shouldn't go uh too far back
as time travels is coming up um
i i feel like there ought to be a
knockout move knight seven i mean knight
of seventies
is the feeling i mean knight has he says
is screaming
to be played somehow it feels like
exactly i've seen something like this
before but
i don't see what the finish line is just
yet and he's played rook back to c1
that's not it i'm going to tell you
whatever it was it's not
it's not rebecca c1 no it's not
that's not the one that you're not going
to see that in
in his best games i was about to say
i really like the move g2 g4 for a
number of reasons number one it wins a
tempo
it's a very nice thing to do is win
secondly i like making love uh on the
king
and last and certainly not least
the night by by kicking away the bishop
the knight will never land
on f5 now there might be some reason
that he was afraid of
playing the move g4 but g4 would have
rooks he won no not on your life i would
never have played
rook c7 he just actually played rook c7
and oops excuse me and back
that was that sequence could have turned
things around
and given black some opportunity to
defend by the way the bishop could not
end up on the
e4 square if attacked and then the
d-pawn will straight
hang so rook c1 was a practical move he
didn't see what to do
why didn't he play h3 instead of rook c1
if you're going to make a move
just exactly waste ways to move with h3
g4 if you didn't see g4 which i think is
a really good move because bishop e4
could have been met by
f3 it looks exactly so trapping the
bishop
trapping the bishop on the square so i
really love it forget knight f7 what i
said that g4
looks like a serious it looked like it
would have been a serious problem
but this might be rooksy one rook c1
soft move in h3 queen b5 i don't think
and now f3 wow that time pressure is
really
coming to roost in that position
he he was afraid that black was ready to
just go bishop e4
and uh snap off the d5 pawn so f2
f3 not a good combination of moves f3
and h3 and bishop c2 and jeffrey
beginning to feel like
hey the tide has turned i've weathered
the storm
i'm about to play knight f5 attacking
the queen and the bishop
by the way the another nice benefit
suddenly of this bishop c2 is bishop b3
could be an awkward move to meet uh by
the way definitely
a big swing in this game sorry i just
wanted to say
that the game between um christopher you
and sam seveon rages on
and the position is getting wilder as he
remains on the board we just saw the
move um
the king went to e after king e7 white
had this choice between playing knight
f5
check and knight c6 so he played knight
to c6 but my concern now is that
we're forced to trade queens which i was
hoping to avoid
maybe not maybe let's see you do it i'm
just thinking if king d7
then be forced to trade queens no
ninety five high jack nice you up so
king d7 is not playable
king d okay well that's why he played it
then and king
and the problem is king d7 95 95 queen
v2
um you just lost a queen and if
um we play king d6 you have rook f6 jack
that's right rook f6 and by
the way tonight note note that
there are starting to be these end games
material issues in
end games that could happen he's played
king d6 what's wrong with
taking on on d2 rook f6 king c7 take on
d2
and then take the a7 pawn and then f7 is
hanging with check
yeah but we didn't win you know we won
one you want more already you're getting
it yeah
right i i suspect that king king c7 may
be
an error i could i think sam
after rook f6 czech was is likely to
play
king c5 the king is that strangely
enough
actually safe on the c5 square and how
do we keep our queens on the board here
because why
i want to try to i don't want to go into
the end game and just
win a couple of pawns you win e4 and c3
like
no no no that's not gonna happen i'd
rather keep my queen on the board like
play queen
b1 or something like that with the queen
before mate threat
yeah well i i think the attack would
that would have been
quite compelling in fact to play for
this line with rook f6
but he's decided instead to play knight
a7
he is going without any risk once again
but
this allowing the move he's up two pawns
but allowing rook to a8
forcing rook pretty much forcing
uh knight to b5 would check king c5
hitting the knight it's going to be a
very
active position suddenly for black is
rook's going to land on a2
even if you play knight d4 which looks
natural he's played king e5
even saying play your next move your
knight
i mean oh wait this move does seem
strange king e5 does not allow rook to
e2
what's what's the magic here why would
you put your king on e5
wow i didn't even realize it was
possible sam may have
overplayed his hand not realizing that
the simple rook e2
a moment ago the rook was landing on a2
and i suddenly thought oh black's not
going to lose
that position with the active rook the
active knight and the active king
king e5 rookie too excuse me uh where's
the magic
indeed maurice i mean
even if he i mean he's instead decided
to go after the c3 pawn
but even if you get this position
what was wrong with getting the one with
the king on c5 and the rook on e2
that's actually so attractive exactly
exactly
and uh here uh well two pawns
okay i agree the that there's a bind on
the queen side and
uh the spawn is weak but two pawns you
really think that white
should have a near-winning advantage
here
no losing chances no losing chances
first certainly in his pocket
christopher has the draw in his pocket
against the number five
junior on the planet he's 13 years old
if he wants to play knight b5 and repeat
he has that the question is what will he
do with only a minute and five seconds
left on the clock
oh wow i think he's going to keep keep
pressing here i mean
there's nothing to lose right absolutely
i mean you could lose on time so i
couldn't say that
he played for me what was a pretty
obvious choice as well
since the rook was attacking the pawn
he defended it blocked it with knight b3
and instantly by the way came sam's
retort knight to d6
he's not threatening to take this pawn
because i'll have knight d2
but sam's intention is to play knight c5
oops rook knight d2 rook c3
he let him in
and we have king f2 on the board so now
only a one-pawn advantage
he was probably going to lose this pawn
because of f5
uh eventually but this position
if you have to play it you say i got it
i'm up a pawn
and you i'm i'm not trading knights you
can
you can fantasize about the rook and
pawn end game
although there's a rook there is one
no i don't want to see a rook component
i want to play knight f3
and ask you where you're putting your
king right
uh just kick the king
he played parade and going for rook b2
which again is the no
losing chances variation but i gotta say
this is starting to look more and more
like it could be a draw guys
yeah definitely do you guys want to
check out some other games
sure there's just time scrambles all
around first of all
um i haven't even looked at all of the
other christopher's game
christopher shen playing against praveen
balakrishnan
and um doesn't look good for the for the
other christopher
at all in this event as look at those
two major pieces
in not that game i'm sorry to interrupt
i'm sorry to interrupt
but you know when there's a sacrifice
it's got to be a sacrifice alert
and in the game with jeffrey and john
there is some spice
going on right now as we were talking
about knight f7 many moves ago
look at the board now is inflamed
well okay it liquidated quite rapidly
i had such a funny position to talk
about but if you just go back a couple
of moves yes you'll see what i'm talking
about
right here just make the next couple of
moves knight f5 queen e4
knight g3 queen e1 rook takes d5 and
after this trade
bam on f7 two knights hanging the
desperado sack
but in just a couple of moves things
liquidated and we're now
in this position which black black can
now say
uh i don't have good winning chances i'm
the one
i'm the one who's trying to win this
position big turn of events
knight seven played a bit too late
yes and he has clipped them
in queen upon endings uh and you want to
ask who has the advantage
you always look to who has the most
dangerous pawn
and by clipping this a3 pawn
black has the most dangerous passive
this pawn on a4 is a real danger
of just running for uh
promotion so uh no question
that is jeffrey in the driver's seat
that
can he bring the the the point home i
mean
queen and pawning games are notoriously
fickle
very very difficult to say i like his
chances
if he avoids a perpetual check meantime
chris and sam
savion do look as though it should be
a technically drawn end game a foot
there but it's
white if anybody was thinking about
doing anything
in this position but we would predict
that one to be a draw
meantime the other game too bryce and
josh
crazy game we had said this one was
black for choice after all those
sacrifices black was up material
why does one back the material in what
just looks like a chaotic position
i like black bishop for sure no question
about it right and white's activity
but you can't call this one with only 12
seconds left
on the clock for white oh boy maybe i
can call this one
it's gonna be hard not to blunder in
this position meanwhile
looks like he's about to force
resignation against christopher chen
that game is just completely dominant
black is up
a number of pawns and is also um about
to checkmate
christopher as well looks like a very
smooth performance for praveen
it does indeed it looks like black has
certainly
got uh this game in the bag he can
capture on e3 and just trade down
everything
and then he really will be uh quite a
number of pawns
he'll be up four pawns yes
i'm happy with one right final trick
final trick king h1 on the board
hope the guy doesn't see it in time
pressure take my rook on c1 please
please just do it
king f8 what is strange move
boy he actually played g6 in this
position oh okay
so okay talk about a ghost in the
machine uh
i was about to say why don't you play g6
and he did in fact play g6
he did and he's and now he can we can
just take on e3 nice finish
because queen rick takes e3 there's a
queen and queen takes e3
nicely done queen and um yep this is
this is a nice nice win rookie one check
um ushering a second queen and there it
is praveen has won his game
let's go back to bryce and josh exactly
by the way there's a draw i don't know
if we said it but there was a drawing in
the game between jacob and jacobson so
that right
ended we have one result in the books
there
right uh we just turned our eye for just
a
flash and now josh is completely winning
as is somehow he he managed to win like
all the pawns on the queen side
and pushing his pawns through is
uh josh he's about ready to go a4 and d4
and well three parts to the good that
one's over
sam and christopher sam was able to stop
the
u train as christopher was not able to
convert that position
heroic defense by sam by the way i have
to say i thought he was gonna die a lot
sooner
but he managed right he managed to come
up with some enterprising moves
particularly his king marching up the
board
that saved him and so that game
looks like we have a result even though
i see the two players still sitting
there why is it
say that we have a draw where is that
am i missing there
we see the players they're still sitting
there though maybe they're just watching
maybe just watching other games as well
that's that's
what they're doing as they're very
curious about what happens particularly
in the jeffrey jean game
as jeffrey could take an early lead
which is not
what sam wants to see happen his main
rival
winning against a very strong powerful
john burke
while the youngster
holding uh holding sam to a draw
that's a bad start for sam he's
he survived but he's still got to be
thinking i should be beating the kid not
letting
that point slip away but i think right
now survival should be something he's
happy with that position looked
terrible and he did some good moves to
keep himself in the game like king e6
looking great and by the way it looks
like we're gonna have potentially if
jeffrey wins this game
um three decisive games all with the
black pieces
whoa that's remarkable uh
a4 a3 i understand
uh the desire to push
the pawn but uh also i like queen takes
c3 jeffrey's got his own uh
technique but okay he did capture the
pawn on c3
now i think he's definitely winning this
comfortably
no chances whatsoever of a perpetual
check by
white it's easy to cover the king
any further checks we can put our pawn
in the way b5
and jeffrey should win
uh quite an up and down struggle i want
to say
it did seem as though he was in trouble
that rook c1 was definitely soft
early in the game not the kind of move
you want to play obviously
but it is now
in the driver's seat it's hard to beat
these guys these 2 700 players
even if they're only 19 years old maybe
especially if they're only 19
because they're so resourceful uh and
optimistic
if you will queen d4 there it is
game over jeffrey winning and looks like
john is in a state of shock because he
knows he had a great position he sure
did and again when we we saw
a time just oops excuse me it was a
round move
early early early right here what was it
uh something he got his
rook right here you really had the
feeling that
white was in control uh we like the move
g2 g4 to press
the initiative and somehow from this
position
well jeffrey took over as uh john played
it
frankly too passively the move rook c
one was
as you said maurice a step in the wrong
direction
you know it's funny i just turned on the
engine and
it gives g4 bishop takes g4
oh whoa what
yeah okay that would have been uh that
would have been a weight again
a serious knight f5 knight f5
working king and queen bishop and
mcqueen yes
i'm sorry and stopping knight h6 check
if you were thinking that the knight
just got to g4
to do some that's an amazing i know
i know they look so good to play this
move
and it turns out that it was a mistake
and the engine is giving h3
of almost as the best move in the
position
what a shame that there was nothing
there
why does it even give much for white
well great barriers
it's going to be a crazy event jeffrey
zhang pravian
valley krishnan and joshua shang all
start out
with that big one point as there's
plenty of tournament
left to go but you know chrissa yep got
her championship title was seven and a
half um i think
that this tournament is gonna be very
tightly contested and we're gonna see
fewer points for first place
and we're gonna take a quick break but
we'll be back for game two of the
2020 u.s junior championship
[Music]
this has been a tough time with covid
and the way 2020 has gone
what have you been doing personally to
relax
i really enjoying just going outside and
shooting some hoops
and i also just a big sports fan in
general so
there are a lot of sports going on i'm
following everything
baseball playoffs are also coming so
definitely excited
for sports besides chess my other main
passion is music
and i guess playing guitar is kind of
therapeutic
especially during these times when
there's not a whole lot to do
yeah one way it's good because now i
have a lot more time to focus on chess
just relax with me with school and yeah
it's it's a good break for my brain um
i'm
i like defense that's definitely the
sport i play i enjoy doing that
i enjoy playing music especially the
piano and i enjoyed just sort of helping
out in the community as well
i think you know i think most chess
players we're just like ordinary people
you know i'll
you know watch a football game with my
friends or i'll just you know
you know play some music other than
chess i'm also um
well i'm gonna be majoring in economics
and computer science so
the juniors is kind of like a way to
distract myself from college life i play
a lot of sports
basketball tennis soccer and i started
playing piano this year and i really
enjoyed
biking and uh reading plenty of books
different kinds of books
there's a lot of fantastic players and
tough opposition in this tournament
what do you hope to accomplish in this
event uh for this tournament i mean
i'm not seated particularly highly so
my expectations shouldn't be you know
too high but
um i do hope to just play decent chess
and uh have some fun
play play well do well i don't
i don't have a particular score or
something in mind
i'm looking to well i'm looking to score
a few points that's that's really it
um well i hope to win right that should
be my main goal
and of course if i don't win that would
not be ideal but regardless of the
result i'm just going to try to play my
best and
hopefully do decently
this is really going to be the biggest
event this year for me and i'm hoping to
just play good chess i mean i'm
probably like too big of an underdog to
win
but if i think if i play well i can
finish in a top position
i want to play well in the us junior to
be confident in the us championship
time control-wise i mean it's a great
experience playing against
other top players in the country i mean
i'm a grandmaster and i barely qualified
so
it's of course an extremely strong
tournament and i'm hoping for the best i
mean of course i would like to win but
if not it's still an amazing experience
and i'm glad i
got not to participate in this i'm
coming in as
the the number one seat so there's
always a little bit of added pressure
um i'm assuming that most
uh usually players will be more cautious
against me so hopefully i'm able to use
that
to my advantage oh uh to win it would be
nice
the st louis chess club is pleased to
announce the expansion of our
world-class chess facility
the 20 000 square foot expansion and
upgraded facility
will feature new ground-level classrooms
supporting players of all ages
as well as expanded tournament and
community gathering spaces with
state-of-the-art technology
accessibility upgrades including a new
three-story elevator
will provide access for all participants
and allow even greater community
engagement
in the great game of chess as a proud
resident of the central west end
neighborhood for over a decade
our hope is to build upon our investment
into the community
and solidify st louis as america's chess
capital and preeminent global
destination
for lovers of the sport we look forward
to seeing you in our new space in 2021
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 u.s
junior flows as we have three players
who won their first game all with the
black pieces jeffrey zhang
praveen balakrishnan and also joshua
shang
can anyone get to 2-0 make a real
big statement on day one well
we should take a look at the pairings as
well to see the likelihood that that
might happen because as we know
all of the winners from last round will
now be playing with white
um jeffrey plays against christopher
shen
he's coming off a lot so that could be
tricky for the young shen who actually
got into this tournament by winning the
u.s junior open
joshua sheng is playing against john
burke and
praveen is playing against nikola cheka
who had a pretty solid draw last round
so um for for burke and shen
they're up against it they're playing
against winners after
just having lost their game moments ago
tough position to be in
yes never tough never easy i should say
to deal with the laws in rapid chess
yeah and from the first round for me
uh the impressive was praveen uh he
he won a really smooth game we didn't
get a chance to look at as much as
we were looking at jeffrey and sam's
game but uh
that was very impressive i and i liked
your interview
with him uh maurice you're saying well
the junior championship's a distraction
from college
[Laughter]
we should all have such distractions huh
get a chance
a little bit of money as well national
championship
yeah you bet so many of them are
excellent students he's also playing
against another strong student nicholas
checka
you've got the uh jacobson who's going
to columbia
at you know 14 years old so
really extraordinary students who
combine
both choices and academics jesus
young geniuses absolutely amazing
but we should be getting moves any
minute guys and i'm really excited about
this round um we got
we got moves in one game and john burke
have already started and they've got an
english on pat
yeah it seems like jeffrey jung for some
strange reason
his game is always the last to start and
we tend to focus on him
because he's the number one seed so we
have an english for
knights with e3 oh i love this variation
as white
i won a lot of very nice games a3
castles that is a little bit off the
beaten
path virtually all my opponents have
played either
a5 to try to stop my b4 or
d5 but castles allowing b4
well okay thank you for that and white
has the two bishops
and just a very nice reverse sicilian
type of position i really like this
pressure on the diagonal and you might
see how do you feel about bishop
f3 is that a move that worries you or
delights you
more closer to the delight uh in this
particular case
because my king's not on g1 if my king
is on g1 i'm gonna go
play king h1 so that i can use the g
file
uh the double pawns i'm not sensitive to
the double pawns
so much as i think the dynamic of having
a
half open g file is good and don't
forget that's another bishop that you
just
gifted me so to speak now having said
that
if you're not playing bishop f3 why did
you play bishop g4
just to develop a piece and get it out i
think that whether he likes to or not
uh black needs to play the move d65 and
after
all what we got instead after d3 was a5
gen
a5 uh i
would not have played the move b5 myself
um when i'm whenever i'm playing against
a knight
i've got the bishop my opponent's got
the knight i'm loathe
to give my opponents knight a square i
when i play the move b5
i fear that i've given up control
over the c5 square so i would have just
played bishop e2 and said to my opponent
if you want to trade on it on b4 and
trade rooks that's fine
but b5 was played knight went back to b8
rather quickly
as black is looking to redirect his
knight h2h3
now there you go jen there's a
an answer to your question how do i feel
about bishop f3
white said i want to provoke bishop f3
black said no i'm going to keep my
bishop
and we're up to date with the players
indeed indeed and you lost these
positions for white even though
the move b5 you weren't crazy about do
you still
you still like white i do because i do
like the bishop and i do like the fact
that i have
the move d3d4 in reserve to deny
the square c5 now having said that
[Music]
if i'm going to play d4 i'm going to
want to recapture with the pawn
therefore move like bishop e2 so that i
can prepare to play d4 and recapture
with the pawn
is probably going to get us a position
like this and i don't think that this is
a terrible position for black i think
that this is
quite playable i would say
g4 on the board bishop g6 played in
response of course
now can we get away with g6
we can't get away of playing h4 because
you can just play knight takes g4 i
think
right yeah so that's not good
so what do you think the idea is here at
the light after
tripling his king side structure yeah
i'm sure the intention from white's
point of view was he was looking
to hunt down this bishop
and put his bishop on g2 now whether
that was a good plan
uh jury's out on that one but i i'm
quite sure that was his idea when he
played
h3 it was like take my knight and and
when he played g4 it's like no i'm gonna
take your bishop since you're not
interested in taking my knight and
that's what and he's done it he's played
knight h4
now we have an unusual opening by the
way in the game between jeffrey zhang
and christopher shen if you want to go
to that one is
our top seeds game is underway
kind of a london of sorts with a very
early
knight c3 knight b5 like a verisoft i
think that might be called the
within this knight c3 move but the thing
is you end up having to move your knight
back very quickly so what's the idea
yeah i always thought that when we
played this
we were trying to play knight b5 in such
a way that we could get c4
which is funny because we could have
just played c4 earlier
but right i mean why why
play your knight to c3 then move it back
to c3 when you're playing d4 openings
you're usually trying to get
c4 c3 in so what's jeffree's strategy
here
well if we go sorry let me just clear
the board for just a second
okay i wanted to somehow let me see if i
can do this
i wanted somehow at like when we played
d4 d5 games like we're just going to
have a
you know a discussion you and i about d4
d5
when we play d4 d5 type of middle games
the fight is usually about the control
over e5 e4 now as we know
the theory has advanced so deeply so far
it's kind of hard to create play and get
our opponents out of their comfort zone
so we have d4 d5 and now we're going to
play for control over the
uh e5 square well in this
weird knight b1 to c3 to b5
back to c3 maneuvering one of the things
i've managed to do
is convince your knight not to play to
d7
and challenge uh the fight for the e5
square somehow i got you to play
knight a6 knight c7 98 96
and so white through trickery
has managed to win control over the e5
square that's not the end of the story
because as i started
by explaining d4 d5 black in turn is
trying to
win control over the e4 square so i'm
seeing it jen
as a really rich strategic battle
and uh from jeffrey's point of view
i think he wants to avoid really really
long
theoretical fights
because then he's afraid his natural
uh talent uh isn't going to be
as good uh when he's playing unusual
middle games
that makes sense and he is playing
against christopher shen who's one of
the lower rated players in the event by
the way christopher
got into this event by winning the u.s
junior open last year
and you know i played one u.s junior
close and that's how i got in as well
really yeah yeah i mean junior opens
an important tournament to win because
it's hard to qualify for this u.s junior
closed right
right right so this is a nice ticket
that's the way to get into it that and
the dunker now as well
so rice got into the bank got invited
anchor and christopher got in
via the u.s junior open got it
and we do speaking of an unusual opening
opening sequence and we all are off the
character that when our opponent plays
something that we think is
a little ridiculous you probably need to
refute it right
right out the opening i need to put a
position on the board that you're gonna
feel regret for having broken tried and
true
principles right take a look at this
game right now going on between sam
savion and brandon jacobson and i gotta
tell you i've been just
watching it as it unfolded and i want to
see how an elite player like sam
handle this opening the move start the
game started off with knight f3
d5 g3 and then the move knight to d7
which looks like okay maybe he has some
plan to play
an early potentially early e5
move if we could just bring that up on
the screen
and there we go so e5 looks like maybe
he might want to do that he put his
knight on d7 blocking his bishop
intriguing so let's not give him e5
and then he played the move knight to b6
now it's not every day you see this
maneuver in the first three moves the
knight goes to d7
and then to b6 it does stop an automatic
c4
but the knight on b6 is often a funny
piece and you say well
where are you going from there like
what's your future
aspirations is it only to control me
because
those squares you have don't look like
you'll ever get there
properly so sam just played some regular
developing moves to start
bishop f5 continuing this kind of queen
side development first
instead of king side development after
knight f6
the move b3 to say okay now i have
established you're not putting your
knight
anywhere why is your knight on that
square
well he didn't even care he said i'll
play c6 since you can't play c4 just yet
bishop b2 i'll play h6 i'll keep
temporizing i'm not going to give you my
bishop
knight b d2 potentially playing for c4
eventually
and e6 c4
played a5 and now the knight on b6
suddenly looks
more useful than it should like why
you know if i play c5 you can just drop
back and it seems like none the worse
for wear
but sam said uh i'm gonna go a different
route i'm gonna play for f3 and e4
and this is this position we have on the
board
has this line refuted this rambunctious
knight d7 knight b6 idea
you know it's funny you you're right
everybody uh sings from the same hymn
book you know
control the center develop one piece at
a time
you know don't move the same piece twice
uh we have all of these guiding lines
and then guiding principles and then
somebody comes up with
a bad move knight d7 knight d6 and we
think right
let me get out the hammer time to punish
my opponent
and then the strangest thing is like i
don't understand you know like
it's not refutable it's it it's
a little bit off-putting but
just because you've made you wasted a
move or even
two the position is still closed no no
pawns have been traded
so sometimes you can get away with a lot
and it feels like to me though i do
prefer
white it's not like i have some you know
massive overkill when sam went you know
like c4e4
d4 you know he's probably thinking
gotcha gotcha gotcha but at the moment
it's okay i don't i don't think it's
terrible not so
not so easy and the bishop on b2 it is
blocked for the moment and you wonder
what is
the follow-up he just played king h1 say
what is the follow-up exactly for
white what if black did nothing
right what would white do because the
knight on d2
is guarding the e4 pawn and one of the
dangers of having space
is you've got to guard all that space
and right now
yeah it's a big responsibility and right
now the bishop on b4 says
all right i'm playing this almost like
in the spirit of the alakine
you get your pawns rolling and as soon
as you do it
bam bishop b4 i'm hitting your knight
now your f your
your e pawn is under attack three times
right and what are you gonna do about it
you're gonna make a rookie one move you
don't want to do that you can't move
your queen you can't move your knight
he committed with the move c5 which will
allow
this knight to drop back to d7
still the issue is going to be that pawn
on
e4 it will be under pressure no question
about it and uh
i like this bishop before uh uh
i i had a style i'll just
describe as provocative i really liked
to test my opponent and
force my opponent to maybe making some
uncomfortable decisions
some opponents really don't like
attacking i know that sounds strange
but some players really like to play it
safe right we kind of saw christopher
you
in game one where he really didn't go
completely
crazy after sam right he just wanted to
make sure he was playing
good chess and sometimes you've got a
provocative player a bent larson
type of player that forces you to
sometimes attack
now in this particular case this
particular moment white as you've just
said
sam you know he's just gained a lot of
space but he's going to take a lot of
responsibility
to guard all of the pieces and squares
that he's weakened by pushing his pawns
forward so fast now
after the move c5 brandon has actually
stopped and i don't know why
like isn't like knight d7
obvious and good i see a trick though i
see one trick
and that is knight d7 take on d7
okay and after you play the natural well
it doesn't matter what you play actually
in the next move yeah queen takes i
think yeah there's the move knight b1
ah sleeky knight b1
of a3 trying to trap the bishop
you could take on e4 and argue i'm gonna
get
what is it two pawns no it's only two
after the move a3 because
you get on f3 but then i take and then
yeah the bishop contract i'm not sure
queen takes was
was the right way because you do have
bishop e4 and create some
whatever but at any rate this one looks
like
you're going to be a piece for two pawns
so that might force the move
after knight takes queen takes might
force the move
a4 maybe the only move
in which case now he can play a3 he can
play b4
and now he can stop and think do i just
dominate space with e5
do i play knight c3 instead your a pawn
is hanging
this knight b1 is thorny it might force
you
right now to play bishop takes d2
after c5 you might have to play it
and um after much discussion he's done
it
and yeah it's actually funny var
mentioned playing a4 immediately that's
a that's a sweet idea
after c5 um yeah i guess because
um i i mean you're playing a3 and then
bishop c3 i take it
looks really weird
is accessing the computer yeah but um
yeah bishop c bishop c3
that one has got your attention like
smash that wakes you up
wow what an idea i'm loving it
how many pounds do we have when we play
rook b1 and we play bishop d4 though
we're only going to get two pawns right
we're getting the
the pawn on d4 and then the pawn on b6
where's your night going
this fellow right that is unbelievable
that is a crazy line yeah i don't think
that's fun that's fun
it's hard to keep stuff like that when
you're not forced to see it right when
it's just like another variation that
might be
good or confusing like when if brandon
was forced to see that otherwise he was
going to lose a piece he would have seen
it right
right right and by the way i i var
also alerted me being that varusian is a
great player of the french
great practitioner of it he um spotted a
game where the french was not looking in
the greatest shape and that's the game
between
one of our co-leaders praveen and
nicholas
or nico as he usually goes by
okay let's take a look
it looks it looks like that bishop has
really planted itself
that's enormous
are you sure you said planted strongly
enough
because yeah that's like rooted is what
i was gonna
say you weren't here yesterday but like
um
maurice there was some some beautiful
analogies that yasser was making about
how the positions were flowering
and i was just thinking about you and
the types of analogies that you usually
make maureen
they're a lot bloodier yeah flowering
would
not would not make my my list
of descriptions when when we're
trying some tulips to kill the guy
stomping yes dumping yeah
more belligerence the more the merrier
but man that bishop won't have six
it's a monster bishop uh here's the
thing i don't like about the move
castling though
okay you look at this position and as
you know stars are dancing in your
eyes and so on you say well where am i
going to win the game
am i going to win the well the center is
blocked i'm not winning the game
in the center no the queen's side no no
i don't see why i would win the game on
the queen side rook be one no
no no oh i know i'm going to win the
game on the king side yeah yeah
yeah yeah so now the idea of f3
g4 trying to provoke hg fg so that you
could
utilize this bishop to coordinate
your h-pawn so i'm not a big fan of the
move
castles because it means my winning plan
of
f3 g4 it's going to be put on hold for a
long time
and if i don't get the chance to play f3
g4 well
eventually slowly slowly it may take him
quite some number of turns but
black will bring a knight to c6 he'll
castle
and somehow one day this knight will end
up on f5
so i think f3 and g4 were
needed and castles not needed
good point and i have to say as someone
who hates
playing against this setup in the french
i i'm surprised that var is
that sour on this position yeah i'd have
to hear his opinion and his nuances
because
usually french players are like whatever
i know you've got a great square i know
my bishop sucks
but wait a minute i don't even have this
bad bishop anymore uh
i'm i'm gonna plant a knight on c4 one
day
and you're gonna regret the day your
bishop has no
chances whatsoever on this f6 square
yeah it's doing whatever but
you're not gonna get anything just
optically you're looking like you're in
a great square with nowhere to go
so that position i'm not i'm not a big
fan of that being that closed i'm sure
var can say
the nuance is much better than i can
in that position as that bishop does
look like a monster i agree the bishop
does it's it's just not doing not going
anywhere
but i feel like that bishop at the right
moment it could take any seven at the
moment that's what i was going to say
the right moment that's exactly what i
was going to say jen you channel my
thoughts
exactly because you often talk about
that about how bishop takes knight is
the most important move in chess
which is kind of funny because there's
one of the chess bras is knight takes
bishop so i always think of you because
i'm like wait it's the opposite of what
marie says
that's a mod he's a
knvb right yeah yeah you sometimes do
shows with them so
so you know that right yes in any case
uh var is in the middle of typing to me
in skype so we're gonna get his
opinion um and he says that the knight
on a6 is misplaced and
that's another thing he doesn't like and
he also i think agrees with us that
you know you're this this idea of bishop
f6 is always hanging on you right
right
we have seen the plain old honoree
counter attacking move c7 c5 by nico
as he's looking to put pressure on the
d4 pawn
if he could he would really really like
white
to capture as var was about to say
the knight on a6 misplaced put the
knight on c5 and var is going to be
smiling as uh black is looking to play
knight e4 maybe eliminate this bishop so
after the move c5
i suspect we'll see something like rook
to d1
and rook to c8 by black black will end
up keeping his king
on the in the center i
i would not have played c5 myself i
would really would have
uh immediately brought my knight back
into the
fight with knight b8 to c6 defending the
night preparing to castle long
like my king safely tucked behind
my queenside pawn shield but c5d1 on the
board
yes i like your move i have to say i
like your move i also have to say
that i don't think black would even need
to castle given that
that point says you could play knight a6
knight a5
knight to c4 is back in the position as
well
so until white shows that he's doing
something
right we're just going to smile and say
what are you doing i can actually bring
these pieces to this square that's why
i'm
maybe i'll be afraid of your idea f3 g4
i thought that was a really good point
because
it's so quick it's to the point it's
challenging the position
immediately whether or not there's some
trickiness with knight f5 or something i
don't know but that really is such a
a pointed move saying i'm coming
to create weaknesses now and attack
right now
on your position by the way it was the
direct approach no question about it
very direct
we should we switch switch over to what
is a very curious game and just as i
said it
the game between josh and john
josh and john schengen burke and look at
the knight on g3
look at that move and if you go just
a couple of moves back after the move g5
had been played
so here we see takes on g6 and he took
with the f pawn
get that open file played knight moves
hitting the pawn so
g5 was played chasing the knight
then h4 defending the pawn and then a
very
concrete knight c5 potentially looking
for knight a4
he said i'm not going to give you that
queen back and now queen to f7
maybe there might be something on the f2
square this prompted me to play the move
rook to h2 which he might not be
regretting
because the knight just said hello i'm
coming in
knight g3 you thought i was going to be
locked out of the game but guess who's
headed to the f5 square
when you move your bishop or if you move
your bishop
i would love to move my bishop maurice
because i'm thinking
bishop g2 wins the game as soon as soon
as i get to play bishop d5
uh-uh it's your turn it's like
let me play queen takes f2 and or knight
takes d3
by the way i'd be stronger in either
case
uh you you you're doing great here as
black so
yeah exactly it's like well gosh darn it
i really wanted to get my bishop
out of play uh but i have to keep
the um f2 pawn protected how about
bishop h3
i don't like allowing knight takes f1
right so bishop h3 looks wise knight f2
uh knight at knight d3 thinking about
the f2 square is no longer on top
because
of course the rook is guarding the f2
square properly so
nothing right there and
you are threatening now to take that
knight on
g3 that is a clear and present danger
clear in the position so knight back to
f5 is possible
i was i was thinking that you might kind
of try to
post up with a move like queen f3
just so that taking the knight could run
into
all kinds of um shots
that's a nice idea what's happening here
nice move yes
three yeah and bishop bishop h3 on the
board so we might get the opportunity to
see this move
yeah will john play this move now that
that that was what i was trying to say
maybe in not the very best way
you know some people just are really
really gifted attackers i mean
they may not have high ratings they may
only be sixteen eighteen hundred
uh class players but they can play like
masters when you give them their kind of
positions conversely
other players like the olf andersons of
the world they're playing defensive
combinations before you even realize you
had an attack
they love the defense move like queen f3
pardon me
is like the attacker's kind of move
right you just
love posting up your queen absolutely
in the opponent's territory and this
move kind of preps
e4 it it it makes
uh white's
uh life very difficult i i i want to say
well actually the challenge is what
is white's next move
white wanted a castle and
and bring his rook into play and his
king
out of any danger but so queen f3 really
crosses that uh plan
that obviously is queen d1 the only move
here
yeah that looks like a weird one but
maybe
necessary i mean if i can trade queens
and it's true keep the two bishops and
then start pushing your knights back
then i'm going to be happy so right
queen d1
what do you do there's it feels like
this is where
the the why i have to play e4 right
everything else
uh my my play isn't justified if i don't
follow it up with e4 right you're sure
though because pieces are starting to
get funny what if queen takes
on f3 here well you have that
in between move now knight takes d3
because it's supported by the pawn right
right exactly exactly now my knight is
hanging but
um so is the bishop on b2
it is so the only square the only square
was d2 huh
there was nothing else to do queen of
three is on the board
queen of three there you go so e4 takes
check
king king d1 is not playable if kingdy
was not play because of knight b2 check
uh king david one yeah that's it yeah
because it might be right
then it is inter mezzo yeah right and
then taken whatever happens next is fine
so then the only move becomes takes on
i mean king d2 and then rook takes and
the piece is hanging and the knight is
going to escape
and easily escape by the way your f2
pawn is
actually hanging straight because your
bishop is hanging as well so
yeah so that's now you might not even
have to escape when you're saving your
bishop
right wow so queen d1 e4 means you
cannot
okay but you're still going all in with
this move e4 so e4
question no questions before let's look
at this queen d1 e4
take this guy take on e4
now okay now
well the one good thing is now my knight
on c5 is
absolutely secure remember i was trying
to be able to play d3 d4 when i see
that knight absolutely um fine i
i think that's yeah rock solid so
even if i were to trade queens and take
this pawn
i think that black's okay but i'm i'd
still be
maybe curious about the attack going
absolutely
yeah about keeping the attack yeah
because
again i'm just a presumption
is that you're not gonna take the knight
queen takes
is supposedly too strong for me
too strong for black sorry so if my
knight's not hanging
then black is doing great
doing fine i can't i can't take the
knight i mean queen e3 and queen g1
looks too strong
exactly don't deal with that don't go
this play just looks way too aggressive
right
what do you do okay so that means white
has to be concerned
dramatically so about even
e4 as the next move precisely yeah i
think e5
is definitely a blacks agenda john
looking
to keep the king in the center bring the
rook
into the attack and pound away on the d3
i mean this is very special this is a
special line
he took with the f pawn to get the f
file he put his knight on the side
he then activated both pieces but it
turns out that this idea of putting the
work on h2 was just wrong
well at the time it looked great i mean
until the knight landed on the g3 square
white's
strategy had been to try to keep this
knight
essentially offside right like if that
knight doesn't move
and white gets to play castles the
g3 and f4 protection of those two
squares means that knight on h5 you're
playing a piece down
that this knight g3 is super disruptive
and after bishop h3 queen f3 is
how shall we say that wasn't on the
blueprint let's be clear about this
the problem for white is that white went
all in in this variation by taking on g3
and then this position happened but if
you look at it the reality is if you go
back just a couple of moves and this is
such an
instructive game from a very deep point
right here when the queen landed on f7
so
black white thinks he's doing something
and by opening the f file and his queen
comes back and it has to guard the a4
square and the f2 point
now suddenly f2 is under attack you just
can't castle
you can't castle you can't play e4 to
open up the game
so what do you do you're you're you
think you're playing rookie work h2 is
actually
a little bit of desperation you have to
play something you can't play bishop e2
because your pawn on f2 is hanging and
you also cannot play bishop to
bishop to g2
because bishop g2 if you play bishop g2
in this position
you hang queen takes on f2 with check
followed by knight takes on d3 with
check or the reverse
it's all the reverse yeah so all this is
bad in fact
rook h2 was a was it it wasn't even
um you know when i first saw the knight
on h5 and the rook at h2 what i thought
was
okay the rook is dominating the knight
so for the moment
do we really care that these two pieces
look silly
right the rookie h2 looks silly the
knight on h5 looks silly
turns out it's not dominating anything
knight g3
queen f3 hello i'm in the party and it
just completely changed the game
and the threat of queen f3 was also on
tap as well when the when the knight was
there so now we've got this position
where white is getting tied up in knots
he's played rook to d1
and the movie the movie e4
looks just as powerful as ever
right yeah this looks like a
very nice attacking moment for john
burke here uh the one good thing i will
say in defense of the move rook d1
is it does prepare the move bishop g2 a
moment ago you were pointing out
that these tactics maurice with queen
takes f2 check
and knight takes d3 were possible when
the bishop lands on g2
with the move rook d1 uh white is
prepping
the move bishop g2 he really wants to
kick that queen out now having said all
of that isn't
this move e5 e4 the critical move
yeah i mean it's a minimum in the
position
it's just exactly just the minimum
although by the way
um yes and this game's very fascinating
but
one of our leaders could be in deep
trouble guys as
actually not one of our leaders one of
our top rated players grandmaster sam
sebian um has
seen in huge trouble all of a sudden
after rook takes b4
varusing tipped me off about this
actually and he said actually at the
moment
if you back up a couple of moves um
after queen d2
queen g5 was an excellent move and he
said that already black
is much better because you can't hold on
to all of the pawns in this situation
well we were talking about the advanced
pawns as
you know you you have this
responsibility to defend all the squares
all the pawns
and we're seeing that come to fruition
after this move rook before
it looks to my eyes like black has
simply crashed through
and you're right sam is in in desperate
straits here
as a d4 is hanging the rook and even
uh you don't see that often in just a
plain old middle game
where the rook posts up so powerfully
on the b2 square this looks terrible i
just don't believe that
f5 and f6 with this bishop sitting over
here on h7 is ever going to
secure white any kind of attack i think
that f5 rook takes d4
uh black is the one you know having all
the fun
having said that what else can i
recommend for
sam he's burned his bridges he's he's
gambling big time
that his opponent will will panic
under the threat of a a pawn attack but
there's no panic here for black i think
you know black can
just take on d4 take on f5 and play
queen
to g5 and take over the game
by the way even in this position after
taking on d4
which just looks correct i'm asking the
question
what exactly is and he's done it
what is the plan for white so queen f3
it looks like
f6 taking on g7 at a moment
when i can't even move my rook off of
that square
but if you play f6 yourself
i will be able to play the move bishop
g6
right and then what like what several
moves do you concoct
to create your mating idea i guess you
could play for bishop h4
take on g7 put a bishop on g7 and then
hope you can crash through
on h6 before i ever get
anything going myself because i'm going
to be watching you all this time
just because you know here's the here's
the problem
here's the problem i see it for from
sam's point of view
uh black is going to capture on f5 and
he's going to put his queen
right directly you know to
break up the party and to stop you from
you know ever dreaming that you would
play
f6 bishop is going to come to e4 the
queen can land on g4 any queen trades
means
goodbye to any attack that you might
have even been thinking about in the
meanwhile
the queen side is just gorgeously
dominated this knight is like beautiful
on b5 it
it defends a3 uh it menaces knight c3
for any future
end game that might be uh down the line
so this just looks
ugh awful just just
just playing plain awful and by the way
we
we just got a word from costa kavutsuki
who was once again
um doing social media and reporting for
this event
um he tweeted out asking if anyone could
figure out who was
behind grand master sam savion and i'm
telling you it's someone
who's not looking too approvingly at his
position right now
i thought that that bottom of that face
looked like capablanca
that's bingo bingo
well wow hello
hey all i needed was that slight smile
just a little look at that yeah
[Music]
that's who it i thought it was when i
say you know
we'll have to confirm that indeed later
but you know the thing about that capo
blanca
is that it's kind of a funny game like
let me just give you half the face of
somebody and you have to guess who it is
right right right right right i could
name that tune
in two notes uh yeah give me a quarter
of a picture
by the way another thing that french
defense players
like varusian like myself are very aware
of when
when our opponents do make this fi break
sometimes we have this nice h6
h5 type of counter
attacking move that can really stop
an attack in its in
at once and guess what that was
brandon's decision he played
h5 and again i mean
poor uh sam he's actually pot committed
he's
he's just going all out with the move f6
now the move rook takes g4 thank you to
this pawn
on h5 followed by bishop e4
looks like how is that not brilliant yes
just a tough start great guys i mean he
could have lost his last
game it doesn't seem like his forum is
right but you know the good news for sam
is that he is playing in the u.s
championship as well
so you know hopefully he can get his um
kinks out now as they will be using the
exact same format
as they use here as bishop e4 was just
played
and you know if i could have a couple
moves and put my queen on g5
if only my queen could move like a
knight right now what's that called
again the super queen
yeah an elephant elephant
okay wow yeah but other but the problem
is you know you get to take on
on g2 with shaq and then play rook g4
and
suddenly there's no access to that g5
square absolutely not i mean if you were
dreaming about queen e3 and
and like you were like maurice was
saying too somehow he would
sneak in f takes g7 and maybe bishop h4
you get some
nice dark square compelling attack uh
let me shut that down right away with
rook takes g4
because now the rook will will will find
a great defensive post on the g6 square
and
queen f2 not queen e3 was sam's decision
but
i gotta tell you it's it's one-way
traffic now
and black has black has every single
pawn
still on the board like has all
eight pawns as white pawns are dropping
like flies rook takes g4 will just
munch another pawn as bishop g2 check is
on the board this is almost resigned
if he plays if he takes him plays rook
takes on g4
he has eight pawns and zero attacking
chances
and by the way that c5 pawn doesn't look
that attractive either
then the guy has a pass connected pass
pawn the rook will park itself
on the g6 square and you'll never chase
it off that square in the history of
time i mean it's just never going to
leave
and then it's going to be all about
black's play this this
this is comfortably resigned
unfortunately for sam he won't
he'll keep looking for tricks but sure
really not a great position let's get
back to that wonderful position that we
saw john burke putting a masterpiece
together he did win an exchange finally
with e4 d4 and knight d3
check played and had to sacrifice
an exchange in that game and now
blacks still this night sitting on g3
i mean yeah i'm not leaving this is i'm
in the party but
but at the moment at least it looks like
you still can't take it the problem is
what does
black do to break through right white
is looking for a chance to get some
pieces on some squares
but where's the breakthrough is it even
necessary he still has
himself all eight pawns he has um an
exchange he's an exchange down but if he
could maybe sneak in a move like
d5 and bishop e6
play for h5 as well if you're if you're
not in the right space
that knight on f5 is going to be a big
impediment to that but
you know what you've got to find the
moves you still have to find
the right way to break the position down
where is it
and he's playing rook e4 he did play the
move rookie four
i was expecting knight uh to drop back
to f5 not that i was worried about
taking the
uh losing the knight it was just
actually what i wanted to do
was well frankly went upon but
rook to e4 rook h4
is actually some kind of a threat so
excuse me
because bishop e6 check followed by rook
takes
h4 is going to hang the pawn on f2
so rook takes h4 might be you know a
very
real threat that you simply can't
ignore of course you cannot play bishop
g2
a move that you would love to play
simply queen f2 and you can resign the
game
on the spot so no bishop g2 queen c2
however does defend
f 2 and makes bishop g2 possible
yet again
i was just looking i don't think it's a
good move but it's just funny that
knight h1 is a thing here
knight h1 i'm just saying i can pile up
on it
h1 might run into bishop g2 though i
know i had to show it it is a very nice
a very nice demonstration
if i could yeah there's too much there's
too many things happening
yeah i think you've been poisoned by
nimzovich
that's all i can say but wait a minute
what happens though knight h1
bishop g2 now we're all going to be
poisoned
let's be poisoned bishop looks like it
should refute but then
queen f2 check
takes and rook takes at f2 sorry rook
takes
rook takes on f2 well that cl
what is the knight being down here i
just i'm just trying to justify it i'm
just trying it
one bishop h1 oh bishop h1
instead of bishop b4 yes bishop bishop
h1 that would refute that's right
because rook takes
and then i don't get my check all right
bishops are way more powerful then you
just refuted your own idea i'm trying to
justify your idea
stand up comedy you know you try to help
it's true that we're after it's true
oh oh okay so knight h1
uh didn't survive
so then back to what does
what's the like what's the move yeah
what's the black point
what does black want black has all these
pieces purely dressed up
uh beautifully aggressive well there was
a wonderful
player and he just backed up was rasheed
nejmed enough and
rasheed never retreated never rasheed
would have continued the attack
of course with a queen sacrifice
and he would have said look i'm
threatening check
and i'm going to take the pawn on f2
next
your bishop is bad my knight is good
what are you going to do
and i think rasheed would have uh
approved rook takes h4 it would have got
it's a very nice idea
i love it let's see it approval would it
have worked though
because there is a check and i think
rasheed
would maybe
maybe not have approved us it's
complicated yes but look at the simple
move
that john lady just played the move
knight to f5
you did bishop f5 queen f5 and suddenly
we're threatening work takes e3 check
winning your queen on c2
that's a nasty discovered check no
question about it jen
no but more importantly the more bishop
e2 the more bishop
yeah bishop g2 excuse me bishop g2 i
think and he runs into this one
you need to have a blow there and that
does look
what a move knight takes d4 uh
the idea of course is if you take my
rook
thinking aha i want a queen i want a
rook oops
sorry about that i just had to put it on
as a visual
and if you take the queen with the idea
that okay i'll defend the bishop guess
what the knight comes right back and if
you think ah
now at least i've got your rook
[Music]
but it looks like these two are going to
trade wins with other people because
if burke wow and they'll both be on one
point
but of course burke on the upswing
so be feeling good going into round
three in a game like this
i mean that's nice this is the kind of
game you want to win
you you want to win the tournament for
sure but you always like
to have a game in your pocket where you
say that was nice
i wanted to keep that in mind yeah i
keep that in my best game collections
right collection for the future that was
sweet and
i mean just amazing absolutely amazing
we have
queen dance of pieces queen d1 on the
board
and that does of course invite uh
well both knight takes h4 i think
there's a
there's a reasons for knight takes h4
but i love
capturing central pawns
you and everybody else including
nimzovich by the way
knight takes d4 thanks for the pawn and
by the way that's a huge pawn it's not
just
a pawn but that just opens up the
position along the fourth rank for the
rook
as well as eyeballing
this uh just domination just absolutely
beautiful jeffrey doing we have
drew jeffrey drew jeffrey drew oh he
drew a little a bit while back we didn't
really have to pay too much attention to
that one
but um sam is looking like he's going
down big time as we checked it out last
time
so we we had a couple more moves burke
just played rook takes h4
okay oh gosh the dog takes h1
yeah every move a hammer every move a
hammer
in that one jeez what a great game this
just
this this one could catapult him forward
in the meantime sam's position so we see
two positions right now as we look at
both sides of the screen
we see white wait a second wait is it
winning anything
didn't we say that black won three games
and now in the last round we're looking
at two dominant
black positions again that could be 5-0
maurice i will say this though praveen
is better
propping is better with white so maybe
he'll win that game
right have some value well i mean
thank goodness for that i mean
by the way that bishop on f6 uh did it
so it does support still uh h5 but
crazy okay that was the jeffrey game
sorry
and i didn't see christopher's game was
that also drawn
shortly we hadn't looked at this one as
much yet
um but what do you what do you think of
it i mean
last time i checked i like black um i'm
not so sure anymore
three was just it's a bit tempted in the
game chris chris
but there is a pawn hanging right i mean
i'm
black could potentially bryce could
potentially play
knight takes and win either the c3 pawn
or the e4 i see what you're saying yeah
maybe okay we'll keep we'll keep that in
mind
sam looks like well he's he's struggling
he's doing his best to make
it difficult for his opponent and john
burke just forced resignation
coming back from a loss
yeah let's see how he got chased uh when
we left it we just saw the move rook
h4 rook h3 queen takes okay
not going down without at least making
one
thread of a checkmate and look at this
the king got chased and it didn't last
long at all
that was all she wrote the rook was
about to
be introduced into the position um josh
threw in the towel
precision and beauty come on that was
fantastic absolutely fantastic game
game of thrones game of the game of the
tournament so far as far as i'm
concerned
that was unusual chess played like a
star
amazing game by john burke and we're
switching back to a pre-tournament
favorite sam savion
up against it at the moment down lots of
pawns he's gone all
in on a king side attack and he's just
played
the visually attractive move queen h6
and that's about all i can say
at the moment oh no but what if we play
i'm just trying to think so queen c two
check king h1
uh queen c2 check king h1
i was actually uh thinking about knight
g3
right to just to uh yeah because if you
play bishop d3 we have rook
h6 right exactly but then you do have
a discover check so knight g3 might not
work look at this
oh you like me now you won nice one
no no i for some reason i thought you
had already played the first move
you're playing knight g3 without a
chance oh yeah yeah we went we should be
playing queen c two check first
queen c two check first yeah sorry and
then knight g3
that's what it makes sense exactly
because rook takes allows queen takes
d1 with a check and you know and if you
play bishop takes
now because we yeah
because now the the queen is not on the
dark square with the discovery
now there's no discovery uh that
yep sam looks like he's going down
that's just a win if he finds queen c2
and knight g3
he will have defeated also in style
the number two player in this event so
he just needs to find this
this one sequence is there anything else
he can do that he might be
thinking about actually uh in this
position
instead of queen c2 well
and we have big news on um nico
um apparently bar is telling me that
nico blundered a maiden three
what happened work to oh no oh
he took the pawn on c3 oh
he got his hand caught in the cookie jar
a checkmate with the king
that that well you don't see a discover
check that leads
to check mate oh my god did the king
move
not very often except when you decide to
put your king in the other person's camp
and then take a pawn when all his pieces
are hanging out especially his
rooks and that was that was really
must have been i want to say time
pressure blender but 111 left
that was a big time mistake yeah
this is a cool mate i mean it is a cool
make mistake it's always cool to see
a checkmate in the end game right that's
just
it's surprising and that's why such a
strong player misses it because you
think
in the end game it's like great you're
getting your king into your opponent's
territory
usher your pawn and then it's like wait
a second i can still make it with two
rocks
and um look at that praveen two points
he's starting out with 2-0 and the first
win for white
by the way right right finally
right like i win finally pulled off a
victory
oh oh it looks like uh brandon didn't
find your queen c2 idea yes but hey he's
still up like six pawns
he did and he just took the rook oh wait
did he like me
he did play quincy too and he just said
yeah
let me let let me just uh trade queens
and
man after my own heart he took another
pawn to go with it
but yes he only has seven pawns on the
board he doesn't have it's not enough
remaining it's not enough i mean my
needs are
extra pawns nighttime he played
and there's another pawn that he gets to
take although okay
white got one also white could get two
more and still be lost
i mean this position is just miserable
knight f3 is coming a la tempo because
knight f3 will be threatening also
rook g uh one mate so
uh that would work actually because he
has bishop f2
why don't you just play knight c4 and
just
do one of your pushing baby dances like
yeah just get this guy yeah
what do you have if i cement this knight
and then just
move my king and you don't have any
moves
you actually have no moves after a
knight c4 the king is cut
your king isn't the bishop is useless
and you can't attack anything you can't
attack anything no
knight c4 f5 and then just escort the
the pawns up the board and we do have
one game
still underway that is a result very
much in doubt and they're basically
playing a bullet game
so that is this one looks like it's in
the bag for brandon
um this is the christopher is the only
other remaining game and it's quite rich
yes indeed he didn't take the c pawn he
got the
e pawn instead no
how did this happen he took on e3
oh he traded on e he just traded simply
to get to this position
and now we have this one that is wow
because here he didn't get any
any material and he's just gotten this
position and c4 and wow
can the youngster the 13 year old who
happens to be higher rated than his
opponent as well by the way
yeah yeah bryce got in by the tanker
qualifier
yeah otherwise i i don't think you would
have quite missed the rating
made the rating cut so knight worked 24
knight c3
on the board um that night is finding
its way back to like d5
civilization exactly no
uh you know in this battle between the
bishop and the knight
in this position because the knight has
such a
powerful secured square in the middle of
the board knight d5
i actually prefer the knight to the
bishop and
look at this i love i was going to
suggest this i was looking at this
because
of the a5 pawn but more importantly the
f5 pawn
and this move is critical queen to d6
if you play queen takes f5 there's a
rook f8 but
does it do any damage to white's
position as white
can put a knight on d5 and cut the back
rank
problem to shreds can he get away with
queen f5
rook f8 where does the queen go can i
even be bold enough
no would i take on a5 instead he's
taking on a5
ins just completely he said i don't want
you to have any counter play
put a knight on d5 and you won't have
any tactics on the f file
or the d line and white
what an interesting sacrifice by the
young sure
i'm not sure i like it it definitely
imbalanced the game
uh but okay the knight is still
you know looking i don't like this move
rook d3 that looks like a time trouble
mistake well they are in time pressure
five seconds that means brace
might must have made the move with with
one second oh my gosh
and now the knight is eyeballing knight
e7
check oh no maybe queen takes f5
97 check looks this looks like it
should win queen takes f5
and absolutely just nicely by the way
defending the b1 square so
knight takes that's a great square i
can't argue
against it but green f queen takes looks
so good right
yes two are now in heavy time pressure
that knight on f5 though just looks a
little insecure
and especially with rook be one on tap
with would be one coming yeah you missed
don't lose on time oh my god one second
five seconds seconds no he must be zero
seconds right because the only way to
get five seconds
is exactly he played two seconds you
mean zero point something so now we've
gotta trade
a little bit of time back on the clock
this one is truly heart palpitating
but wow and white push through rookie
five
looks like i would play g4 in an instant
just because
love secured to security
protect the night by the way queen chat
means that the knight on
the pawn on h6 will be hanging and look
at this gaining some time
that was very nice though those queen
checks
that really helped so again protect the
knight
before thinking about advancing the pawn
get a couple more checks in while you're
at it
queen to ca check and you can bring the
queen back because of knight takes check
queen of f8 would allow 986. so now in
queen d7 you got him on the back rank
you might want to move your king to g2
at the moment just to get a little
freebie and get off that diagonal and
he's done so
and the issue is can he get c5 home is
c5 gonna be playable
well okay i wasn't a hundred percent
sure
that i liked the queen on c8 because i
thought i could play c5 and c6
yeah i was afraid of rook c5
but okay in this oh queen h7 he'd
i was about to say he could go after the
h-bond and he did
that and this looks crushing now
knight takes that's that's a winner
queen g8 check
knight f5 check and uh white is
definitely
uh winning this position white is the 13
year old the youngster who has drew his
first game
and is looking to be tied for first time
for first after two rounds guys
um no no no no no probably they'd win
two games i'm sorry yes i apologize we
do have two
we do have a leader at the moment a
player with two out of two
f three okay be
very very leery of opening up
uh the second rank there i thought he
should have played king g3
but okay still how do you stop winning
how do you win
how do you win i want to go
he went check he needs to trade queens
trading queens wins the game
so queen e3
is possible queen e3 no no but that
doesn't trade
that doesn't do it don't need h6
oh wow okay we forgot we had
another passer over here i didn't forget
about that pawn i was just worried that
the king might be under pressure somehow
uh what's your name so queenie won queen
f2 but then i have queen e5
keeping things a little interesting he
played um he did play queen he won king
g2 played
i was far more worried about queen h1 by
the way
h1 was my thought but now with the queen
out of there
i'm thrilled why did he leave this is
this is starting to look great excellent
suddenly yeah now we've got queen check
now we've got the queen trade you were
uh
pressing for maurice queen h8 check and
queen g7
oh that's
definitely would get the game done and
over
and black in big trouble trying to
figure out where to hide the king
there's nowhere to hide the king h7 is
coming i think brace is just
losing on time here oh no he moved but
he just got in the check
he saw queen g7 he says sign me up for
that
ending i'm ready to trade queens and
push my pawn
i mean this this is pointless he's
making moves his queen is pinned
he'll get a spike checked he doesn't
have time to resign
indeed i mean it's just there's no moves
to make it's over
wow christopher you our youngest
competitor
that was a hard thumping thumping game
guys um
zero seconds uh i hope his dad wasn't
watching i couldn't
yeah i couldn't dance because he made
this move
and his clock said five which means that
he made his move with a fraction
fraction of a second just amazing
just in time was that the last year
without play he outplayed his opponent
they rookie five oh boy
oh my goodness all right now that the
games are over i just turned on
stockfish
and stock for says his exchange sack was
the best
move in the position wow
is absolutely the right move and
after the queen d6 after the move was
played
yeah queen takes on a5 was also
precisely the best move to play and by
the way
maurice one other point that that var
sent me
um 59.86 was a massive blunder
because rook takes f3 check double x
clam
um where i wanted to play queen h1 he
had
rook f3 rook f3 and then f4
check and queen just on a pendulum you
can't get out of the checks apparently
you mean it allows a draw yeah yeah
sorry you're saying knight h6 was a
blunder no no no no no much later
much later guys when the pawn played to
h6 when the pawn played to 86
right here right here
yeah because you also have uh you have
like the uh the stalemate right
you're still mated three king f3
that's an immediate draw yeah you're
right yeah immediate draw
and two no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
you can't take one f5 that wouldn't have
to take on f3 because the g pawn exists
i i i'm sorry yeah right yes i'm sorry
yeah and now draws are
eminent and why would rook g4
also work then it probably does
no no rook g4 allows king takes and now
your g
pawn is ah because when i yeah when i
sacrifice my queen you're gonna
take it and free my g-pawn nice nice
little mad rook trick
unfortunately bryce couldn't find it
with no time on the clock
that would have been a super star trick
to find in time pressure
is leading the event with two wins
attitude as
jeffrey john our favorite brandon
jacobson and christopher u
trail um with a solid one and a half out
of two
but we still have one more round of
action today
and we're gonna be back with it right
after our break so stay with us
[Music]
the next story comes from the olympiad
and these days modern olympiads really
revolve around the bermuda party
the bermuda chess federation hosts
a party on one of the free days
featuring some very serious
black rum and everybody goes to the
party and really has
a very good time well one of the great
chess legends in the world from the
ukraine
the seal ivan chuck one of the sweetest
guys you're
ever going to meet on the circuit so he
comes to me and this is basil the sweet
sweet sweet
guy and he's shaking and his
fists he's got his fist clenched and he
goes
yes sir you called me a bad duty
and i could see he wanted to fight me
and he was going to
punch my lights out but what did he just
say
and i said what did you say brazil you
called me of that duty
i had clueless what he was trying to say
to me
so i said could you write it down and he
wrote
b-a-d bad
d-u bad
dude and i go oh yeah
in my magazine i called you a bad dude
yes you called me bad dude what does it
mean
so now i'm searching for the definition
of bad dude and i can't come up with
anything
and i say do you know clint eastwood and
he goes bang bang bang bang
and i go yeah he said you think i'm
clint eastwood and i go yeah
oh friend friend
and i avoided a very bad beating
[Music]
can you hear it it's the sound of hope
and health and strength
it's the sound of compassion of open
doors
where people and machines are in tune
and
miracles occur it's the sound of
personalized health care
and active communities it sounds like
life
and it's what you hear when you really
listen
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton
of fun stuff for families to do like the
magic house or the science center
and if you really want to be a stellar
parent
come see all the new stuff there is to
discover at st
louis union station with a new mirror
maze
light shows and the 20-story high
st louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent
feel like a star st lou is
always exploring since 2009 our mission
has always been to teach and promote the
value
chess brings to our community in these
times of social distancing it's more
important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative
digitally
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession
isn't a notepad camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility a journalist's work
revolves around the truth
finding it verifying it and
reporting it great journalists work hard
to find the facts
and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories offering
facts that may have been omitted
we work every day to earn your trust
for news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
2020 u.s junior championships we have
one more round of day one
round three and here are our standings
with praveen
at the top of the table he's got two
points and then we've got
jeffrey brandon and christopher all with
one and a half points
um and a big round coming up guys let's
take a look at the pairings
for our third round of the event i
always feel like round three is somehow
a really important round and i think
that's even more true when they're
playing
online is it's also a tiring round
john burke just off a win playing
against christopher u
who's um up there in the top of the
cross table also coming up
from a win another big game would be
brandon versus proving is cravings
already strung together two wins guys
yes exactly and i'm looking also at sam
savion
as maurice was saying at the opening of
the show number five in the world
the world's top junior player number
five is sam sevignon
had a minus one score how strong is this
field well we're finding out so is sam
and jeffrey zhang our tournament
favorite going up against nico
um which game strikes your fancy jen
well i think brandon um playing against
probing that's that's a great one to
start out with
absolutely yeah they're both coming off
of victories
exactly and again um maurice you had
interviewed a number of the players and
i was listening very carefully to what
sam savion had said that
he really wanted the experience of
playing this time control because when
you play online you tend to play a lot
of bullet
or five minute or three minute and you
don't really play
a lot of rapid uh chess so you're not
quite sure if you're playing classical
chess or blitz
and uh well he's he's getting uh
the experience but maybe not this the
results he wanted definitely not the
results he wants but at least
he's not doing this in the u.s
championship so right
he can just get those cobwebs out now
right
although it's still going to be some
time in between this event
and the u.s championship because we do
have two events in between that we will
have the senior championship
exactly and we will have the u.s women's
as well so at least
eight days by my account nine days
yeah and that's that's right maurice and
i think that's fantastic for sam by the
way i know he's also participating
in a fundraiser simul um
hosted by the american chess academy to
benefit the armenia fund so sam
is going to be very busy but he's also
going to have a lot of time to see what
he did wrong here
and improve it potentially for the u.s
championship my concern is that he's not
going to have the form he wanted to be
in though it'd be nice if he could play
it back to back
right if you will because it doesn't
look like it's an opening problem
he had he had a great opening in game
two
great opening i guess they're juniors
but still i feel like they could be a
little bit tired
especially if you have a bad result you
won't you don't want to like continue
the negative momentum
so what we'll see though you still have
seven rounds to change things around
right
i mean there are a lot of decisive games
in junior chat so
and he can make it happen right now as
he we've got this rossolimo
on tap um hold on which game are you oh
i'm sorry
absolutely you're talking about sam but
at the moment given that he's in first
but it's where he's russell
it's a very imbalanced position sam's
going to have his chances to try to
fight back and win against one of the
underdogs in the event and at least end
the day with an even
score meanwhile what do you make of this
opening yes sir
oh sorry you wanted did you you were the
brand
okay because you're sorry i
got completely messed up yeah no it's a
catalan
uh e2e4 well that's
a real uh shocker as the last move by
uh ravine was a b7 b6 as he was looking
to develop his bishop either to b7
or to a6 and he's just kind of stunned
by the move e4
so let's try to figure this one out if
we take this pawn
takes there's no bishop a6 because the
knight's not on b8
so that doesn't refute it and if we take
the pawn like this
knight takes this is the real question
this is absolutely the real question
here what is the result
of this position it looks like since f5
is not playable you can play
with because of knight e6 if you play f5
and that would be a
big problem working your pieces then it
seems
that you're gonna have to play something
straightforward like a knight f6
and i never like these positions where
the knights come off completely and all
you have is a little tiny bit of space
just feel like maybe not bishop b7
immediately because of c5
trickery who knows well i guess you
could play bishop takes
on c5 and then take on d2 that's
one interesting line but nevertheless
it always feels like these types of
positions peter out
into nothing because you just don't have
you don't have
something to count on here so what do
you do knight g5
knight f6 seems to trade off knights
what do you what
what's the deal exactly well knight f6
seems you're not playing bishop takes
that just loses when it takes takes
and i mean it is these types of
positions
that you do
tend to want to play because at least
there's some imbalances going on in the
position
uh these two pawns on a d4 and c4 give
white
some kind of a spatial edge if black
ever manage it i know what you mean
maurice if black ever manages to play c6
c5
that's my big concern yeah whatever
advantages you may
think you have well they're they kind of
disappear
on the other hand um well
is it is it is that the position that
uh black wants to play a lot of a lot of
players who play
uh these let us say slav
semi-slav positions they
not looking for a completely balanced
game they want to
kind of keep things a little bit alive
so how about a suggestion of say bishop
b7
you can take with the knight on e4 if
you take with the bishop then i'll play
knight f6
something like this where i'm kind of
keeping
more play in the position trying to play
for c6 c5
right because you actually think that
the other position is too
it rather than being not enough for
white you think it's just too
easy for white to play just uh is like
say it's like i don't think it's going
to be like child's play for you to just
play
queenie right because queensland i can
play c5
i mean i have to watch out for takes and
my bishop hanging on d2
but you know depending on how you
you protect against h7 here you
certainly don't want to play f5 or g6 so
i guess you're stuck with h6
right right elimination right and then
something like bishop e3 and like you're
saying jen
either when when you play either for c5
and or for e5 white's pieces
are going to usually take advantage of
the open roads and i don't want to say
it's two result game but i do think that
white
tends to be the one who's pushing uh
more
than black now having said that uh
this move e to e4 has really
uh surprised praveen
a great deal and he's in the tank
tank indeed and i think you're black you
better be careful
right because if you let white get a bit
of activity as well
then white who's got the in development
at the moment and he's decided to avoid
all of the above and it was like just
bishop a6 with a fork
being allowed yeah just like perfect
timing
and i wanted to ask you guys well what
do you think about
this two pawns for two pawns
uh and a rook for two minor pieces for
example after the move bishop a6
e5 bishop takes c4
let's say i just dropped with my queen
back take my rook
i'll take the bishop and uh
i'm let's say i just recapture
so so i've got two pawns for a rook
against two minor pieces uh which side
do you guys prefer
white or black
well unless white gets some activity
black's about to play the move c5
yeah looks like put a rook on c8 and get
all that play
[Music]
that looks i don't see how to get white
pieces to dominate there maybe my move
queen to d1 is a little too cooperative
let me at least
try to stay active
with the move uh queen and how did you
get the vector bishop a6 again
um you did e5 right away so version is
looking at this and
suggesting c takes c takes d5 that was
my yes i had this thought
c takes d5 bishop f1 and sac and
exchange
directly yeah this is he says this is a
huge edge for white
yes this position i like this position i
like i was about to say it thanks
verousen
for confirming this idea looks
dynamic because now you can't take on d5
without allowing e5 and you don't get
the same
material advantage that you did before
if you don't allow e5 um what you know
i'm gonna i have e6
and c6 under attack like this is a a
brutal
it's a ready compensation it's already
coming yeah i mean which one fantastic
yes
the other model it looks fantastic she
thinks
it looked appealing but this one looks
even more appealing you're right
as a king in the background there by the
way there's one other fascinating game
between john burke and christopher you
currently underway
um as as christopher you was one of our
front runners as well one and a half
going into the round
it was a really interesting game a
french division
where john burke played this um this uh
sacrifice this
pawn sacrifice and um christopher
um denied it if you want to look at the
declined it you mean declined it that's
right he declined the milner barry right
but and instead played for g5 trying to
destabilize the pawn it's funny
he doesn't take the pawn earlier but
then the plan of playing for g5 is to
take the pawn later
right but take it on terms that you're
even more excited about
and we do have we're up to date with the
players we just saw a trade
as we're expecting the move g4
now g4 it looks like a great move until
you see that at least i can play b5
and try to counter punch you so how does
that look g4
b5 g takes f3
if you take on f3 here and i take on c6
you don't have time for any kind of like
funny business like rook g8 or anything
like that
or no because you take on g2 i take on
d7 with check
so yeah this seems like it turned out
okay for white because
at the end of the day the one thing we
don't want to lose is the d4 pawn
and then you know you're you're going to
force a trait of queens we don't want
that white wants to
keep the queens on the board here and it
looks like the material is equal
and white is just has a great position
here right
so that is why christopher is taking his
time here
as he's realizing that maybe the
intended
g4 b5 is actually in white's favor and
maybe he has to take the pawn
and he did he did and immediately i mean
john burke must be
still in his theory it seems like he is
guys it makes sense too because
this is like his main line potentially
for white or his preparation for white
whereas
this is obviously not the main line
against the french christopher yu
would not be as likely to be as prepared
as the person who's just
you know sharpening this exact knife so
we're after rook to b1 um a3 is now the
threat so what do we do
we've got to move the queen like a5 or
something or
the queen a5 sidestepping
the pin and like you said a2a3 was on
white's agenda
um i could go back with a queen but
maybe i'm
kind of loose to some tactics
so queen a5 looks right
yeah queen a5 and now what does white do
so i can't take on g5 because you have
bishop g5 and knight takes d3
right okay we'll cast a piece right
well white didn't go into this to get
back at that stuff because it's actually
even close the hair with like bishop a3
and rook b5 in the position
you're looking at work before here i
suspect uh
he he has some exchange sacrifice
in mind like rook takes b4 followed by
knight takes
g5
that looks interesting because if you
take with the bishop
and here there it is rook takes b4 on
the board yeah
and i suspect this was his preparation
because
white has sure been playing these moves
like if you just look at the clocks
white has spent all of 24 well white's
got 24 minutes let me
put it that way he spent all of one
minute
to uh play all of these moves
and i think that's why this line is
white against the french is somewhat
appealing because it is a little bit
more of a narrow path
right like he has to see he clearly like
studied these lines with g5
and um this is
all in his crap which way do you take
back on before i i assume you want to
take with the queen so that
you have the protection of the bishop on
e7
yeah i was thinking that i take with the
queen just because i wanna
i i feel like i'm i'm on a roller
coaster
ride and i'm probably gonna lose after
bishop
a3 but uh when by the way
he took with the queen and knight takes
g5 again
i mean white is gaining time on his
clock
jen i mean he's like all of these moves
bang bang bang and i know how
christopher is feeling because
it's not he doesn't feel like he's
playing an opponent
he's he's feels like he's playing
against his opponent's homework
it's very it's very scary right now
right
i mean bishop that line you show just
looked horrible bishop g5 queen b4
bishop a3
that didn't look like something i was
going to survive i mean
like knight c5 or something and then i
have knight b3 it looks like it just
wins on the spot
yeah it's something terrible yeah this
is
the this looks like really uh
gross like yeah yeah yeah
all kinds of things have gone wrong
suddenly you're here for for black so
unfortunately for black you can't take
now
maybe rook g8 and just
hopefully yeah lucky in the stars i
don't know
i think so i think don't take that
knight um but
it still looks oh boy it looks so
dangerous and especially knowing that
your opponent might have the next few
moves calculated too
as well yeah
you're attacking my knight so i have to
decide whether or not to play like
whether the move knight f7 actually
works or if i'm just going to play
knight f3 just bring bring bring the
troops over
uh queen f4 on
white's agenda knight f7
and queen h6 also the issue yes
the issue is not is not rook g8 i mean
the issue is
again what are black's best moves white
is white signaling a threat at the
moment is it 96 is a knight f7
why do we need to attack this knight on
g5
and even your you know your last move of
knight f3 what is going to be the next
move
is it going to be knight f7 given that
he can play bishop g5
so for black what black wants is to pick
the knight up off of d7 put it somewhere
take the bishop off a c8 put it
somewhere and get his king
out the middle as soon as
possible any the moment you say i can
castle i am gone that's all i want to do
i'm up in exchange
and how do i get it there and he's
played a remarkable choice
knight back to v8 that
it's he's thinking the same thing i was
thinking
but putting the knight back on b8 is not
what i would have wanted to do
that's how it's cool and the way i would
like to get my beast
you really believe he's thinking he's
going to get enough time to play knight
c6
with tempo on the d4 pawn then play the
bishop and then hopefully get time
to castle which by the way f7 is hanging
so he's still got work to do when he
castles
that knight takes on f7 will be on the
agenda so i'm not sure this solves all
his problems
i don't think it solves any of his
problems i think knight v8
uh compounded the problem i think you're
absolutely right maurice he should have
played knight b6 bishop d7 and get out
of dodge
by castling queen side asap the problem
with knight b8 of course the knight is
superior
on the c6 square then the b6 square it
does after all attack the pawn on d4
the problem is precisely what we're
looking at right now
is that you just don't have time for all
of these nice things that you're trying
to do
moves like rook f8 might just end up
getting splat
uh by night i mean i could have played
knight h7 and
been a little bit more pedantic but
knight takes f7 and bishop g6
looks like a crusher so the problem is
that
you just you you don't have the time
that was not the way to do it he needed
to get his knight to another square i
wasn't sure
what that square was going to be frankly
maybe e6 yeah
knight b6 again we're talking about the
speed of the attack so knight b6
and now if knight f3 bishop d7
and if queen f4 just
castle get back get give back some
material just to
something up to get out of this and now
tonight is actually pinned so
you know you're you're kicking here i
mean and you know on a good day you get
to play king v8 and
maybe you hope for the best yeah you got
to tickle right
exactly that should have been a clear
direction knight b8 is audacious
well the only good news for christopher
is that his opponent is thinking for the
first time in the game because
apparently 98 wasn't at the top of the
tree
i'm sorry that could be good news or bad
news
the bad news is your move is not in the
in the book at all
the computer didn't suggest it that
means i just need to go find
out what's wrong with it exactly yeah i
paused for a minute but it might be
a minute that i use to destroy you as i
find the right way to go and of course
knight f3 on the board
and we see queen f4 looming a
thunderous threat looming clouds now
over the youngster's position by the way
you went after my f8 rook yas in one
line yeah and i was thinking please just
take the rook is that all you want
mercy be merciful just take the wrong
take the
exchange now yeah just take this back is
that all you want
i mean just be kind be nice
like this right you're like yeah go
ahead you can have the right place let
me count like let me
let me get out of here away just could i
castle on the neck and the brother get
out of the middle of the board please
that's just all i'm asking for
but instead you said no sack on g7 and
they played bishop g6 like
oh that hug that hurt i didn't i didn't
appreciate
them takes queen upward landed on the
board and i love how you put it maurice
good news bad news
i didn't even think for very long but i
got to tell you one thing i like having
this
john burke in this tournament it is like
his games
have been like absolutely simulating and
he's going to be natalia
cervantes of this tournament if he wins
this game right three decisive games out
of three
wow he did nine out of nine worries she
had five wins and four losses
amazing amazing that that's
that's a little bit too much
she didn't have the game at the
tournament talia did not
have the game with it but she had the
move of the tournament there was this
awesome move this rook d2 move she was a
rook down oh i saw it
i didn't see it the bishop came back
and see through him taking the draw
that's right that's right no perpetual
checks for talia that was an amazing
position that was a nice
game you know it's it's
it pays to be young i know right the
older you get
the less it's like you're going to live
on the edge every single move
right you you used to party and drink
and go out late
you hit the 40s you start dragging in
you never drag maurice no no
little hennessy now but ah yes
but uh but indeed but by the way we have
to take a look
look at jeffrey's jeffrey's game because
jeffrey uh he's being hunted by
nicholas who's decided that
it's only it's only a pawn sack at the
it's not even a pawn sack actually when
i look at it
he's uh jeffrey is playing a kind of a
variation we called the hippopotamus i
don't know if it's called that
way today but uh one fellow who played
the hippopotamus was one tigran
petrossian
he played it in the world championship
match against
boris spassky an f5
and we've got that position
i mean what happens after bishop h5
check where you putting your king
that's what white is thinking about uh
what's to thing about it
well it's the intermezzo because perhaps
jeffrey was thinking that he had this
little treacherous idea planned
that he was going to castle and maybe
eliminate the bishop
put the rook on f4 and the knight on e5
but the but you're absolutely right
maurice it's this
whoops hello the jeffrey
oh why aren't we doing that and he
didn't do it he just took back
immediately
and but you know what you had it it's
still there
you can do it twice why not play that
check now in this position
i have to admit there is the possibility
of king f8 and queen f6
i don't want to trade but it is a pawn
sack if it happens
let's take a look at that bishop bishop
h5 check king f8
queen takes on d4 and now
queen f6
exactly we can't trade queens because
knight takes
hits your bishop wait a minute i didn't
have bishop f3
and but i don't want to play this boring
position and you got out of
most danger here right because here he
can play c5
and shut everything down after you take
on on d5
you don't he doesn't end up with a
weakness on the c7 square
you got your pawn back but so what this
is yeah this is no party no we don't
this is not what we want what you wanted
okay so instead he's just like queen
takes
immediately but still but i mean f6 is
possible and it's on the board
yeah i'm a little bit well i'm a lot a
bit
confused i thought that jeffrey played
bishop takes d4 with a very specific
idea of castles and the ideas let's say
you take
and then in such a position jeffrey
would put
his pieces on the dark squares of f4
and e5 and the queen would go to f6 and
you know that was his plan
um his plan wasn't that his plan was
this
that's in front of us his main point was
to play for this position it looks like
with queen
on f6 right now and he's saying i'm
going to get a solid position the other
position you talked about
that c7 pawn would be weak and the
bishop on b7 would still be on the board
looking for a home even though you've
got a couple of dark squares at least
for the moment
uh g3 might kick you out of there at
some point
yeah as with that setup that you played
right so
so this line he's saying i'm going solid
i'm going to prove to you that you have
nothing despite this
what looked like a good move bishop to
h5 check
exposing your king it's a clean pawn
sack
in fact it could be a double pawn sack i
know this kid
is thinking how dare you leave your king
in the middle of the board and have all
these weaknesses
how dare you how do i get you how do i
prove this wrong
but exactly not clear how to do it
uh let me just uh take a gander here
uh i'm gonna try queen d2 so
i intend to meet d4 with the move knight
b5
and i'll win back my pawn that way
with a good game take my pawn
i had intended to play f4
or maybe bishop check first followed by
f4 well you don't want him to castle
queen side right right so f4 allows
castle's queen side so we need the king
to do something first
now this is the gamble position we're
playing
right what's happening here and i always
feel
like when we get into these matchups uh
where jeffrey is the big pre-tournament
favor
favorite is to put the favorite under a
lot of pressure
right not to make his life easy and
and you know this kind of a gambit he
did play queen e3
the reason i played queen d2 and not
the move queen e3 was i didn't like
queen e5
because in this case it's somehow
magical the queen went from d8
to e5 like what and it was like
yeah so black
basically his queen on e5 in my view is
simply too powerful it's really a great
piece
really yeah yeah but but what if he do
what if you stupid check him check him
on h5
okay let's say i go king d8 okay so now
what is your next move i'm trading
queens and i'm taking a pawn
okay i just want to make sure because my
point was i'm moving my queen but
i just want to know if you're taking
your pawn because i get to play rook
a rook to e1 and f4 as well and your
king is still stuck
so let's say you play like this and
rookie one
oh okay so i've got a tempo another
annoying tempo
that's annoying i i know what you mean
you were just about to play f4
a second ago
i got you by a half a ply
and i want to play queen e2 knight e5
g3 but knight f3 comes with
authority so it doesn't seem like i
i get there yeah knight f3 or
some crazy move like that okay
he he didn't see what to do so he
decided to go just for the positional
advantage
transferring from one exposed king the
advantage to
a weak supposedly weak pawn on c7
i gotta say i'm not that impressed by
this position for white
i think that i prefer black's position
i'm about to say
i think black's gonna have easy play in
this kind of position
right i don't see this bond as a
weakness especially for example after
castles and i just see this knight as
a tremendous piece it just plug
it defends some business squares along
the
the file it plugs up the e file and you
know if you could play rook f8 in
castles long in a single turn
i would almost call it a decisive
positional advantage for
black the only reason i didn't suggest
rook f8 right away
was i knight b5 i might
find it a little disturbing to play
against knight b5
let's go back to that game with john
with john and chris because
he played knight eight seven instead of
the move knight takes g6 which does have
some tactical
[Music]
complications associated with it yeah we
we we didn't look at the
ramifications of a line like this but
okay i'm sure it's good for white by the
way uh
but knight h7 was his choice yes and
rook g8 on the board and rook g8 and
the kid is trying to defend his time
pressure
could be a factor as he's down a full 10
minutes on the clock at the moment but
then the other night
the other night comes to g5 this looks
fantastic
i mean what are you gonna do now like
you can't move back um rook jesus
looks oh i was just going to say rook g7
looks bad because of knight f6
and then i'm hitting your rook
after you capture it oh you're oh you
can run after a night of success run
yeah run around
i wrote wrote this book king walks and
i'm afraid to say the book is uh rubbing
off on me i'm seeing king
walks in too many games but i'm
expecting the
the king to run jen knight f6 check king
to d8 i think well it's important it's
important the rook
the rook is well placed i mean it's not
the greatest piece it would love to have
everybody around it like
another rook on h8 actually i like to
pick up the rook from a8 and put it on
h8
right now let's discuss the position
exactly
but that's not going to happen for a
while
in the meantime though the d4 pawn is
indeed okay i was going to say it's
hanging that you defended it
so so much for that yeah i got to defend
it because of that
yeah right and now could i please get my
rook on a8
into the game i mean what the heck can
we play bishop d7 and king c7
one day can bishop d7 be real but rook
b1
is also a move yeah i was just going
after the h-bond maurice i had to defend
the knight on g5
so that when i played knight on f6 to it
takes h5 my g5 knight isn't hanging
but you're right it's going to be also
considered uh
rook to b1 and rook takes b7 in either
case
white's exchange sacrifice is paying big
dividends on the king side
i wasn't looking at rook b1 as much i
just it just
happened because of the move bishop to c
bishop to d7 which means
i can't play bishop to d7 i have to back
that move up
because b1 is too concrete in addition
to your h4
what do i do i don't want to waste time
with b6 could i play king
oh i can't play king c7 because of 98
check
yeah in the immortal words of larry
christian said i'm getting you from
behind
oh my gosh that's pain and
so i can't do that so what am i supposed
to do
i think you got to play queen a3 it's
not like
you're happy i'm at least
for the moment tickling the bishop if
the bishop were to retreat
play something like b6 and just
you know pray that you're
you're you'll get your pieces out uh i
just feel that
once white gets in this beautiful h4
knight takes h5
he claims the game it's just too too
awesome
i think uh i think christopher along
with his time trouble woes
is realizing that his position really
is under fire what else is going on jen
well um we should uh go back to that
game between
um brandon and praveen
or actually actually christmas okay you
know what let's look at christopher
and josh because that game is looking
really interesting as well well
interesting
particularly for josh
is black doing well again geez
sometimes you have those tournaments
where white just wins every game and
it's like
whoever plays black and whatever black
is doing he's just getting
crushed and smashed and everything and
then sometimes you have this
really peculiar tournaments where white
doesn't seem to
get any advantage out of the opening and
so far it's
it's one of the peculiar varieties uh
this looks
promising for black hey wait big news
yes big news sam is down in exchange
but he has a pawn for it sam seveon
we haven't looked at his game as much
this round because
this is a nice night oh this is a really
nice night and these pawns on the queen
side are
nice and this is a rossolimo opening um
so i can see the textures of this
this is why black has the two bishops
because there must have been
a bishop c6 earlier and now the pawns
hold on hold on guys
look look at this you know curiosities
are
bread and butter right how did this pawn
structure become this pawn structure on
the queen side
yeah that's how did it happen it was a
so it must have been
c6 d take c6 yeah but then you need
another
a what you need a bunch of captures for
this to happen
yeah knight captured ah b4 okay
and there we go that was a very peculiar
yeah curiouser and curiouser
uh a5 wow why do you need a5 but okay
bishop d2
i suppose uh bryce is
thinking about knight g5 and maybe on a
good day
following it with g4 and sam to play
so sam has a pawn for the exchange right
yeah he's basically winning on the queen
side
right so and he has invited bishop
bishop to g7 white's all in
on the king's side trying to make his
rooks work you can be up in exchange
congratulations if your rooks are not
doing anything there's no point
there's no worry on the side of the
player who's down and he can play for
his own activity the problem here is
what exactly is
black supposed to be doing as well it's
like both questions
both sides have the same question what
are we supposed to do
well from white's point of view i mean
clearly the move bishop d2
was designed to make way for knight g5
and it
try to cause some issues for black so
for example
h6 let's say i go back
now do you want to play g5 which gives
me
you know sacrificial possibilities if
you go king h8
well i mean you're saying 77
back yeah g5 g5 go ahead let's see it
let's bring it let's go let's go
i guess queen g3 you you have to start
worrying about the sacrifices on
a g5 i'm not worried about the
sacrifices i'm worried about you playing
this solidly and trying to make my
position look terrible
after h4 you didn't even sacrifice i
noticed the way you said
ah you have to start worrying about
sacrifices and then you brought the
queen back to g3
and played h4 well i wasn't i wasn't
sure that the sacrifices right away
like necessarily lead anywhere right
like
it should look like it leads it doesn't
look like it leads
uh to what you really want right maybe
it looks it looks
good suspicious it's a little suspicious
looks a little
suspicious no but your idea of queen g3
and h4 just looks so natural that it's
going to cause
real pain for him as well so let me just
go back and forth to get an
update on the current position and we've
seen a repetition by the way
after bishop dc bishop g7 bishop h6
uh this is so it's possible
that after day one sam will be
minus one yep
quite remarkable back to that game with
john burke by the way
a5 played by the youngster cold-blooded
hit me if you can but your age four
is on the board and now bishop d7
i'm not sure what a5 did in this moment
i i don't think that really helped the
cause so to speak
but here unfortunately it's not about
the queen side the pawn on b7
falling or the bishop on d7 being traded
it's really about the king side going to
to ruin i mean if the rook
which is under attack moves queen takes
f7
e6 pawn comes under attack but knight
can easily swing its way
back to f6 and by the way that h pawn
really is passed so it just feels like
you know uh christopher got
really out prepared very very nice
preparation by john
burke in this game down 10 minutes on
the clock as well
for people who struggle against the
french is he got a really nice attacking
game yeah
right out right out of the opening let's
just quickly jump back to that
ending that we were kind of liking for
jeffrey he jeffrey went rook f8
knight d5 and then
okay and
well uh there were some confusing
moves there that i didn't really quite
understand but
now that we're here what is here shall
we
ask the obvious question what does
jeffrey intend to do about
f4 he's been trying to stop this move
for a while
but maybe he's hoping the pawn will move
too
far too fast something like this
yes yep and now your king has to go to
let us say a lesser square now
here uh my spidey sense is tingling uh
this this
this tells me i've got i've got i got
stuff in the position
the king is is is bad
uh how i take advantage of it that's a
that's another question
but the king is bad all right let's see
so push
push and how
how do we judge such a position the
spawn on f6
is limiting the ability of the king to
breathe i want to play bishop e6
that's my impression
yeah you're almost forcing me to take
this
piece off well this one might be your
best piece in the position now if you
trade it off you do give me
uh a really good look but i was gonna
play king d7 and rook
i worked his work to d.a we're to ea
we're eating it
i'm trying to prove that you have a
weakness but you won't let me get in
there
you know you're never going to get me
because like in one game you were saying
maurice that you wanted to go
if you teleport your rook you wanted to
go rook on a8 to h8 if you could do that
you'd be better
yeah get out of the middle please
please please please maybe i should have
played rook f7 in that position
okay but i still i'm because your knight
is tied down so rook f7
and knight is tied down united is tied
to the d pawn so if i
and f4 is on the board so f4 all the
moves were taught
all the moves are on the board we're
racing
towards this position the kings are now
on d8 and we're anticipating that move
you played f5 so if rook f7
the idea is to play we're currently here
so the idea is to play rook f7
wait a minute there was another okay f7
yeah
sorry i had another idea it was but rook
people were coping
what if what if i snuck in rook g8 back
up what if i stuck in rock g8
where here right here yeah um
i think you're asking for a world of
hurt
i know i work f7 is solid but what what
is your move
cookie one takes and now i can't
i gotta and if chad you got you have a
check you have a check
that's important because you could play
king of d7 yeah
yeah if i could swing so i'm too
ambitious because you stopped me from
being able to play king e8
and i can't play king e8 right now
because you have check right away so
okay so let's keep it going i take your
bishop you take and i play workout seven
we we
yes yes yes from this position mm-hmm
and challenge you here i want to play
king up rook over
force you to defend all like everybody
i feel like it's one of these really
amazingly sharp
end game positions and like everything
depends
upon a tempo right like if you get rook
e8 and rook e5
you win the game because the pawn on d5
is lost
if i get in g5 and g6 i win the game
because i win the game right so what
happens on 48 now
i i think that's a very good move
uh i've got to defend my knight
unfortunately
i lose time if i have to defend my
knight
oh even allowed it to be pinned hmm
yeah it's like wow these are
uh oh razor sharp yeah the razor start
position i see and then
yeah this is this is an interesting one
which will probably continue for a
little while but one that won't continue
very long i don't think is
john burke's game against christopher
you as
we um i think are seeing uh that one
close out soon knight
just went after knight h5 yeah as you
suggested now you just went back to f6
and sorry that's not a repetition of
position when you um
have taken a pawn from the road right
he didn't and he didn't take on f7 well
that's
remarkable i mean that that pawn
had my name written all over it
literally we see a y and an s on the
bottom of this
if you pick it up it didn't say howard
stopped
and it said yesterday no we just need
the y and the s we know that's the
answer
why oh we know where else is
and look at this last move this is going
to force the end because rook b1
and because of that pawn on east i mean
you can't even defend b7
and once seven goes i mean a3 rook b7
i'm running queen
seven mate so you can't getting his
revenge in this one
white's getting big-time revenge for for
the losses white suffered
in previous rounds because look at look
at brandon's game against praveen
pravin these these knights
are dancing and prancing
if you look at that position the move h5
move
uh what was the move before this a
knight e6
look at move rook d7 96 so the
group moved and he said 90s he said dare
you to take my h-bond that's not going
to happen
and dare you to take my d-pawn that's
not going to happen but the knight on e6
stopping both moves
touch nobody touch anything okay nobody
touch anything and then after
b5 he just played eight six
look at these this domination has got to
be a win
somewhere what is those most
well i don't know what's the most
accurate but the most natural would be
to
play rook g7 and just say okay
uh take take my pawn if you
you if you want and then i'll i'll win a
rook
so for me h5 d6
uh too many scrumptious looking moves
d6 looks like it's just completely
shutting doors everywhere
meantime black's counter play includes
a5 b4 and c3
and even when you play b4 by rook takes
c4 so that's not a
variation so white's biggest problem is
actually finding the construction that
ends the game rook g rook g7
a5 yes like what are you doing while
he's making moves
i don't think he's you're making moves
uh very much longer though
uh
just waiting for your threat to
materialize
okay just just just to clear
clean things up a little bit right
just to clean things up a little bit
look at those nights
they're just oh they're awesome
yeah sometimes we fall in love with
bishops you know because
the bishops like are scorching on two
diagonals and they're just
doing everything but sometimes you fall
in love with knights and this is
this is such a moment where we can sit
and admire
uh the capability of the knights
yeah that's funny yes because i feel
like you know everybody knows you love
pawns that
you know that that is usually mentioned
within the first five minutes of a
broadcast
right right be pretty um equinamious
when it comes to
um bishops and knights like you know you
love them both
well i really do and i actually
think that the knights
make chess such a magical game
in other words we have these letters
yeah
your bishops move on diagonals rooks
move on ranks and files and queens do
the same thing
but the knights man they flicker and
go everywhere they're easily my favorite
piece
and i do believe i said it earlier in
this broadcast about
the position when the knights came off
and we only had
the two bishops left right
that the position just seemed dead to me
once i saw the knights go off
i just felt like these linear pieces
aren't going to do much
to do damage in this position it's
really about the knights
and we do see the knights dominating
here and he just
dancing he just took the pawn on b5 he
gave away
his pawn on dc on d5 which looked like
a joy a pleasure to have i know
so that he could put he can shut the
door on
this road this rook now out the game and
eight
six eight seven happening and that's
gonna be
all she wrote complete and utter
dominance
and there it is the cavalry there and
resignation so now
beautiful game by brandon excellent game
by brandon
and praveen with two points still very
much in the running
but his perfect score uh is now history
now and uh and jacobson will leapfrog
him what a game and it's true
that's amazing maurice that you
predicted earlier in this game
the um you know you were like no i don't
want to trade off all the nights and
then it ended up in this position that's
hilarious
i mean let's see the the burke view game
um
uh finishing i know john burke totally
winning but in positions like this with
the king in the center
you just you just kind of enjoy watching
it go down
i mean there different
get to the test tournament and you know
there's a huge huge crowd around a war
right right the vultures they all come
over to watch
watch the bones to pick on the bones and
mercifully it's over he's resigned
indeed now has two points two wins
one loss christopher great bounce back
nice showing by christopher you want a
great
round two game and like you said yes
it's hard to fault him that much in this
game was
it was just an amazing preparation for
burn
toughness it truly it truly is and that
i i you know when you play chess you're
going to lose games just
get used to it you you drill for it you
you you just put up your best resistance
but the worst kind of game
to lose it's a game where you don't
really feel like you ever played it was
like your opponent just went
bang bang bang bang bang and you looked
and he had more time
when the game was finished than when
they started and you go
well how much of that was your original
analysis
well everything i mean you played all
the moves that lose
properly and you're like oh so that was
really
it's not fair that that those are the
hurtful games now
let's turn our attention to the game of
sam savion because sam
coming into this game one of our
pre-tournament favorites
was sitting on minus one we thought
the game was going to be ending in a
perpetual it has not
the players are playing and i gotta tell
you i like sam's
position a lot and i like his clock too
three
three minutes to one minute that could
prove significant in a complicated
position
exactly and i just wanted to point out
before he played the mcqueen b6
that you can defend upon how sweet it is
you can defend the pawn with queen g6
while simultaneously threatening maton
one
and as we know jennifer mayton one is a
strong threat
deal with it d4
okay huh d well that sounds like a good
move
okay so now with your move queen g6
but that's what i'm trying to understand
i'm trying to understand why sam
felt it was a good idea to provoke
the move d4 because d4 looks like
it's on a better square than on d3 yeah
but after queen after queen g6 what is
your next move
that's a question too i guess yeah i
mean
i i like actually two walks into b3
exactly rookie
oh although that may not be the end of
the story after rook to f2
because the pawn's not necessarily going
anywhere
and again you're the same question of
why did you
put the pawn
and he's instead played g4 which looks
compromising
wow and maybe compromising after 95
wow g4 okay
that's lifting the kimono yeah but queen
g
oh queen g3 queen g3
okay queen d2 not minding h5 happening
to him
this just got crazy what is happening
crazy
in a way that you know with lots of time
in the clock you know
it's anyone's game but i feel like black
is just
so much easier to play with white's king
exposed and that solid
d5 and hey two minute time advantage
is huge as well capablanca looking over
your shoulder
yeah yeah i don't know what blanca would
get me nervous if he was looking over my
shoulder
lately absolutely you've gotta go you
gotta you've gotta
you've got to up the ante on all your
moves when you're capturing
but i'm i'm wondering though because i'm
again i always like to know what my next
few moves are going to be
right to see the flow of the position
and i don't exactly know what black
should be doing especially after
something like king
f2 uh yeah
so white's intention is king of two so
if you play a move like
h5 oh look king f2 is on the board so
there we go
the issue is what's your next move
because h5 is
exposing your position exactly well so
he's transferred
the whole game and he's played f4
complete sea change
i like this one i like this move a lot
maurice because
uh i didn't want to play h5 and open up
the h file against myself
the king but i do like the move f4
because
if i can just go i can i can squirm my
way
into the position with a queen h6 queen
h4 and that's why we saw
h4 queen h6 and i gotta tell you
under h1 under to rest bryce is finding
some good moves
i know wow
again the question what is your winning
plan as the rook on the c file
dominating the one open line on the
board is making life difficult now
queen's swinging to
this square e6 i want to get my rook
up you just played rook g1 you know his
time pressure is huge now though 21
seconds
only that's really critical for this
young man
it's going to be very hard to finish
with to defend properly with so little
time
sam's really keeping the pressure on
he's moving quickly trying to keep his
time advantage
um but also consider his moves at the
same time and he's played knight to c3
work takes g4 ideas here now as you know
we got a fork on e4
of course if you move the rook on g1
away gotcha
yes sir could you do could you do me a
big favor could you pull up on
your board nicholas and jeffrey because
we have two exciting finishes
going on and we don't want to miss
either one an exchange sacrifice
in this other game on the right and the
analysis board
and jeffrey trying to prove that this is
not enough
in this position while sam is trying to
win his game will
jeffrey be able to pull this one off or
does white have enough compensation
as it now looks like the pawn is
dropping
on f7 right definitely two result
game here jeffrey uh for choice
oh that's the end of that
i'm glad we turned to that just when we
did
the timing there as bam jeffrey zhang
leaps into the lead with this
knock killer blow that's a mike tyson
uppercut right there you walk right into
king e5
rook f5 perfectly on time and did you
notice that jeffrey played that look
instantly i mean was he ready or what
oh and it looks like sam is breaking
through
is yeah he just just sacrificed tonight
and now is it over how do we do f if we
play f3 check here
king f1 and the queen on d2 protects all
the key squares right
except g4 queen f2
i mean after if you check me first so
sam decides to take the pawn on g4
first 15 seconds left for bryce 30 for
sam
is this winning what about i'm not as a
queen
what to do h5 what h5 is the last thing
to do what that was just
well he didn't he didn't see a move was
his problem he just
didn't have a move so what about rook f1
shouldn't rook f1 be the move queen
if i played rook f1 and move my king
back even
okay now i can't play rook f1 um
now he's played it yeah rickett phone
looked like the move on the last move
on the last turn yeah on the last turn
because then i just fix everything and i
get a king a running square for my king
like he might have been winning v3
what is sam doing sam's bluffing
sam's definitely bluffing now he threw
out b3
and he's making the position a complete
mess a hash of things but now rook f2
and you have no tactics anywhere by the
way yasser you're king march you're
you're infecting everybody
because that king is going to go to d3
and c4
and it's gone yeah and he tried to queen
h3
to stop the king from rushing away i i
thought
he was going to go queen h1 at once
and look at this why didn't he do it
f3 in that position rook cf3 but still
crazy guys 12 seconds left for both
players exactly
you're just glitzing now anything five
take five what is that he's gonna he's
he's gonna
he's got kc4 and now he's winning the
king is gone
sam bluffed and he's in trouble oh yeah
exactly
trouble now as the king has escaped on
c4
and look at that work on g4 it's inept
right now exactly
absolutely rook to g4 it wouldn't be
useful but bryce you got to move
four seconds and he's queen to e2
nice move hitting the queen and the rook
good move forcing the black queen to go
in the direction it did not ready and
now he's ready
for before that was a good move nice and
now you have no moves with black
desperation trying to get something
going isn't that f pawn
actually hanging i feel like taking it
he munched but maybe there's something
me too
oh it wasn't edible it wasn't
edible now the whole game has shifted
yet again he's gotta take this thing
he's gonna take that
he's back in business but who's better
oh
baby there's a big past pawn in the
position though
guys look at this pass it's a yeah
that's a big pawn but that the queen is
tricky
i mean we're just very tricky you do
want to get your pawn to b6 somehow
rook rook to c4 just to defend the press
price move
okay he he keeps getting
down to just seconds on his clock now
look at this he's going to go king a4
and he's going to push the pawn
the rook is ideal on b2 okay
how does that stop b6 he wants to play
a3 but he does nothing you play for k2
oh no rook a2 is a terrible move with
lightweight queen b1 check
he could have played rook g2 check
instead and now the b-pawn is
gone and we have the makings of an even
position
oh no oh no but the king is in a
terrible square
now there's h d5 threatening rook h4
mate
be careful be careful i don't want to
lose a room
there's no tactic that wins the rook i
don't see i don't know i mean
i don't like leaving those very
protected oh there's a check on a those
are check on a5 maybe
a checkered a5 was deadly he missed the
check on a5 in that position they're
both panicking
because queen a5 check looks very strong
and now a
check oh this books are starting to
become disconnected by the way
yeah queen e5 and queen d5 right was
probably yeah
but anyway he had rook a4 queen c3 and
the game would have gone crazy
but here we go can the rooks join each
other again
this has to happen maybe rook c2 is the
right way to play he's brought his work
to b3
and here we go a double example that
could do it if he wants right well
no check no the rooks are the rooks are
going to be potent adversaries
in this position in this defender oh no
but he's disconnected his rooks again
okay he can always draw he could die
that's it he's just gonna draw rook b
that's great what a roller coaster
game this this game why does he need a
draw why not
why not rook b4 here why take oh no no
no he i think he's going to draw now
he doesn't he's he's been through a lot
maury
we're done we want to watch more i want
liability insurance it's not just the
emotion
but i mean i need health insurance keep
getting down to two seconds one second
on the clock that was too touch and go
oh my goodness oh my goodness
there were so many blunders by everybody
the players the commentators
that was insane for the
fences why we like the juniors they
place they play so
um so many exciting positions such great
time scrambles
oh wow that was a lot of fun
how did he how did how did bryce win the
night
what was sam doing oh this is where sam
came up with the genius idea of knight
e4 check losing a
knight for nothing he could have done
what you wanted
jen he could have played rook takes g4
maybe
he thought rook takes c3 rick takes c3
there
okay yes you're right
he was probably afraid to venture
into a line like this yeah because i was
actually thinking in this position i'm
dying to play rook c3 even if you don't
you know give me a run right i just want
to get rid of that night
i know the night was too much oh my
goodness what a game but knight e4
check looks like he he he
over estimated his position i thought
rook f1 here would have been
quite strong instead of a dragon it just
seemed like a
just consolidating yeah h5 looked like
robot i mean out of nowhere that was fun
though that was really cool
and i i think that we're we have a tie
at the lead i believe right now
as we've got indeed jeffrey john our
pre-tournament favorite tied
with brandon jacobs in it both young men
have put on a show today
winning two games and drawing one um
john burke
also i mean lost his first game but
dazzling
back-to-back victories um a little bit
less happy but still with two points
and that's because praveen on the other
hand won his first two games
really nice games and then lost his last
round
and we have a special guest jennifer
that's right we do have praveen
balikrishnan
with us hello praveen it was a dramatic
day for you
yeah it started off well ended off
poorly but
still a good result so far
yeah tell us about um the players in
this tournament that you've had the most
experience against playing because i
know you know you've
been a veteran of the national high
school championships
who do you um have the most battles
history with
um well probably brandon because we used
to
both live in new jersey and we played a
lot there so we probably have at least
10 games
against each other and all the other
participants have played them
like a few times like maybe two or three
times
but yeah brandon definitely like i have
the most games against him
well he's leading the tournament right
now
so um which game you guys want to take a
quick look at with praveen because he
had those two victories
um starting off with christopher shen
and then you also
won against um nicholas checker who
which game did you prefer
exactly which one which was the one you
thought was your best game
was probably the one with um
with nico i'd say
and where did you think the turning
point came in this game
uh with with nico or with christopher
with nico
that's the one with the well i mean it
was like
i thought i had a good position out of
the opening and
yeah so bishop f6 queen e2 and if yeah
so
i saw this c4 idea like uh
after rook c8 and i was pretty proud of
that move
because it that kind of puts him in a
bind
where after everything got traded off
or queen takes c4 queen takes c4
dc for d5 then um like his king is
stuck and he had to resort to giving up
his c pawn
to like block with this knight but then
um
there was no like clear way for me to um
break through on the king side because
the way the pawn structure was even
though
i had an extra pawn there was no clear
way for me to
like create a pass pawn and took a lot
of time
and eventually his king came in
and i wasn't really sure what was going
on at one point but then he
blundered mate in three oh yeah that was
that was awesome
a king checkmate we love to see it okay
i guess it's not really a king checkmate
um but uh did you did you instantly see
that you had anticipated it yeah
yeah i saw i saw that when i played rook
d5
i thought he would have to play maybe
rook c5
and yeah i wasn't really sure it's kind
of a race
because i have my h-pawn but he probably
will
make his own past pawns on that side too
and we're both in time pressure too
so anything could have nice when they
fall into your trap
yeah craving
yeah i've never seen anything quite like
that before a really nice one for the
kids watching at home for sure
but it's good to get your king active in
the end game but every rule has its
exception
yeah there were so few pieces he
probably didn't realize that
his king was almost getting mated
so are you planning on making any draws
in this tournament or just all decisive
games
um well if if it's all wins then i'll be
happy
with decisive games
and here it is uh his results so far
wins against christopher shen
and nico checka and a loss in the last
round
to brandon jacobson who's now tied for
the lead with
jeffrey jean well praveen thank you for
joining us and good luck tomorrow
we hope for you another dramatic day and
a good one
thank you take care see you tomorrow
wow it's always tough to start off the
score that he has he has two points
right but his two is not the same for
example as john burks
is two although he does get a rest so at
least there's that right
you know it's not like he has to play i
think it's always really hard in these
three rounds a day
i mean three rounds a day absolutely
absolutely that's a positive
way to look at it but still he's
thinking
i gotta come back right that's his
mindset coming tomorrow
while burke is thinking
i'm on a roll first game behind me
i'm i'm ready to party could we play the
next round now please
do you see how i'm playing right now i
mean his games
have really been the showcase of this
tournament
i mean honestly both games he won were
just
brilliant just just special
so he's going to be somebody to watch
but at the moment though
he's not in the lead he's only a half a
point behind with two other players who
are saying well
we're at an elite so you should be
talking about us i don't know why you're
bragging on them
and we have another guest yet speaking
of being in the lead
we have jx in the building
uh jeffrey welcome congratulations on
your lead right now
uh hi uh can you hear me guys yes we can
okay
and we only see your eyes so you might
want to back up just a little bit of the
camera so we can see
yeah i'm trying to pull up my video
right now i can't quite see
anything very weird okay
um is that let me know if
it's anything good all right that that's
good enough indeed by the way i know for
sure you had the heat in the finals
against the lakers that's what i'm
guessing
uh no i wish i could say that um i i
i was on the clippers for most of the
the year
so yeah i was pretty much dead wrong
about it okay
all right i'm joking because i know
you're a huge sports fan and you're
following all the nba and
everything but this is the tournament
we're at right now and
you are now at two and a half how did
you feel about your play today
uh yeah overall i wasn't too pleased i
felt like
i was under pressure in all three of the
games i i felt my opponents were
actually outplaying me
so i definitely need to raise my level
in the next two days
is there a game you play that you really
felt badly about like
you really feel like you stole that game
the i felt like i stole both of my wins
okay nothing was clean today
and this last game you played your king
just kept trying to get out of d8
d7 had to go back to d8 that looked
weird to say the least yeah and
it wasn't ideal for sure but on the
other hand i didn't really see
a convenient way to to operate um
it was probably i think he
maybe missed a moment or two where he
could have done better but
at this point i felt he has a past
f-palm but i have it more or less under
control so
it was roughly balanced for a long time
and i was able to use his time pressure
to my advantage
do you see this event as a completely
separate event
from the u.s championship or potentially
it's a warm up to you for the us
championship
for sure it's a warm up it's it's a very
good warm-up because
i feel like all the players in the event
are going to pose
significant challenges to me it's
already evident from day one
so i definitely think uh it's it's a
great
tune up for for the u.s championship
that said
this is your last ever junior event you
turn into a man
in uh is it the 30th is that your
birthday the 30th of this month yes
so you break into the big 2-0 how does
that feel knowing that
the junior days are about to be behind
you
yeah it makes me feel really old i have
to say
i know how you feel jeffrey i i i did
that
yeah it's just very sad that i remember
i think my first juniors was in
2011 and it's just really reminiscing uh
these old times i've always enjoyed
hanging out with
my fellow junior players and definitely
will miss this event
incredible oh jeffrey it's great put it
in your pocket
it's great to see you here jeffrey as
we're we've been used to that
this summer watching you play against
magnus and the top players in the world
and now it's you who are the favorite so
a little bit of a
different dynamic for us watching you
but it's fun either way
do you feel the pressure of being the
favorite
um not really it's more or less still
just
playing good moves on the chessboard
that's what it comes down to so
not really feeling any extra pressure or
anything
always very cool jx in the building
thank you so much congratulations
on your performance today and we look
forward to seeing you tomorrow
thank you thank you jeffrey good luck
good luck
he's one of the coolest competitors i
know like absolutely
zero emotion when he's playing you
cannot guess anything that's going on
his mind
he could be wailing on you crushing you
you don't see a smile on his face
he's got a poker face he does he there's
even a famous there's like some famous
photo of him um
at the chess club with his hoodie on
black and white
yeah he's he definitely has it and i
believe him that he doesn't feel a lot
of pressure because it's like
it's one thing to be the highest ranked
player but he's the highest ranked
player
but he's not like 50 plus to win the
event right there's so many gladiators
so he's still going to feel awesome if
he wins it you know
testing sam savion and eight other
hungry lions
absolutely and we have
a co-leader of the event with us now
brandon jacobson coming off a really
special win
in the last game first of all
congratulations brandon you must be
feeling pleased with the day's result
we don't hear brandon yet brandon we can
barely hear you we're going to try to
fix the audio situation
hi brandon better now
better got you there okay what did you
say
yeah i think i did well with my time
management most importantly today and
i took the opportunities i was given i
don't feel like i necessarily played
such amazing chess but i just
kept the time advantage and just did the
best i could given the chances and i
feel like
both sam and praveen were definitely not
in their top form today so
i just took advantage of all the
opportunities i got
what was your favorite game or favorite
moment
from the day today
um your mother felt was was special
probably against sam just it felt like i
was
heading into a little bit of trouble but
then i sort of just took control over
the position and
you couldn't really protect all his
pawns like
i think like i think this idea of giving
up the two bishops for the light squares
is probably inaccurate
um i think instead of queen e3 you
should play e5
and then go a4 and just completely um
shut off all my counter play on the
queen side and then
i'm probably in a bit of trouble but i
feel like especially in rapid these
types of positions are always like
really hard to play for white
because you have the initiative you need
to prove something with your central
pawns and then it's easier for me to get
a counter attack
if you're not careful so yeah i think
here i mean
i see here the computer said it's equal
but i think it's already really hard for
a white practically
right it just didn't have great play in
this position actually you won the game
fairly easily which is surprising coming
against a player of
sam's skill level
yeah i mean he did have a lot of tricks
but there wasn't really much he could do
like he's down two central pawns and the
attack isn't really getting anywhere so
just needed to avoid a few tricks and
then it was pretty easy from there
i don't know if you're particularly
impressed by your h5 as well i thought
that that was really
let's call it the showstopper just
whatever
you know what whatever fantasies white
was having h5 shut them down so that was
a real all-star move from
for for me sorry uh maurice
no not at all you may not have had
huge aspirations coming into the event
but now you find yourself tied
for first any thoughts now
potentially seeing that trophy on your
mantel
i have to take it one game out at a time
because the next round i have black
against jeffrey which obviously is not
an easy pairing so
i'm just gonna do the best i can and see
where it goes
that's the professional answer
definitely
the right attitude well congratulations
you're tied for first in the u.s junior
championship
good luck tomorrow thank you good luck
brandon
good luck yeah he played a wonderful
game against sam that was cool that was
something definitely to be proud of and
now
he stands atop the leaderboard but as he
said black against
jx that's going to be
an indicator i remember watching
you guys play you guys doing commentary
or following the commentary
and it was wasn't it carissa beating
annie
in the first round uh on the second day
that catapulted her that kept her going
yes
and put any put any backwards right away
right so that was
very important first first game out the
gate
he's got to hold hold jeffrey back
right there that's a big game for him
could really mean
winning or losing the event uh just
right out the gate
because jeffrey if jeffrey wins that
game and catches a nice roll
especially with sam only with a point
jeffrey's got two and a half sam's got
one somebody's got to slow jeffrey down
as far as sam's concerned
because if jeffrey starts rolling and
gets that form that won him the world
junior championship
back in 2016 yeah you could just be
watching this guy
clean house the rest of the way
absolutely
we're being asked who we pick from oh
you should have asked us that the start
of the day
so we have all night to research it come
on guys i'm
gonna go with jeffrey
soccer
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go with the highest-rated guy
who's leading the field
let's see who do i want to pick
[Laughter]
well i don't care what anyone says i'm
going to
make the show boring and copy yes sir
all right number one player in the
tournament yeah i think jeffrey's gonna
hold it down
i want to find out who huh ah
var is picking jacob okay far speaking
brandon jacobsen i want them to be four
different people and now i have a tough
choice between john burke and praveen
i mean john's prep was awesome probably
transitional play
but i'm gonna go with john because if he
just gets prepped like that a couple
more times
hey it could be lights out for whoever's
in front of him
right well i tell you if you had asked
me before
play started before uh the first game i
would have said sorry
jeffrey and then we would have all had
different picks but
uh when jeffrey jeffrey starts two and a
half out of half
and looks good he says he wasn't happy
with his play
exactly that's the worst way to prove
you're the guy i want that guy i want
that guy it's like when magnus goes yeah
i didn't have any good games today
but you're leading by like two points
yeah but my play wasn't so good you know
it wasn't perfect you're crushing the
field yeah but i could have won two more
games i could have been passionate
i shouldn't have let that guy escape
these guys
are are perfectionists and animals
they're
sharks right you don't want to just win
they want to win correctly
all right well not enough our schedule
we got
three more rounds tomorrow and we wrap
it up on thursday
october 15th round seven through nine
and our potential playoff guys this
day was full of so many amazing moments
i can't wait
for tomorrow and we'll see you same time
same place
expect more of the same tomorrow for
sure so tell your friends where you're
hanging out and thank you for joining us
good night everyone good night good
night
[Music]
you